GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ALL WHO ARE JOINING US
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS TO ALSO
VIEW OUR REGULARLY SCHEDULED
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE HEARING.
A FEW HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS
REQUIRING THAT MASS BE WORN AT
ALL TIMES BY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE
IN THE ROOM OR AT THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE WILL BE
DELIGHTED TO PROVIDE YOU WITH
ONE. TODAY WILL BE LIMITING. ME
TO PUBLIC WITNESS TESTIMONY TO
TWENTY MINUTES FOR SUPPORT AND
TWENTY MINUTES FOR OPPOSITION
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT ALL
BILLS ARE HEARD. TODAY IF YOU
WISH TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY BUT
UNABLE TO DO SO DIGITIMES
CONSTRAINTS. WE ASK THAT YOU
SUBMIT YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. VIA
THE EMAIL TO THE ASSEMBLY
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE. WE OF COURSE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. WE
THANK MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC OF
JOIN US ON THE CHAMBERS FOR
JOINING US. TODAY WE HAVE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT HUNDRED ARCH
ALETTA AND SENATE BILL EIGHT
TWENTY SIX. BY THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH SHOULD BE TAKEN
UP ONCE A QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED.
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL PLEASE RAIE YOUR
HAND IT WILL. ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. IN ADDITION
TO BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM WE HAVE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS
LOCATED ON THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. FOR
DIALING WITNESSES FOR.
INDIVIDUALS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO CALL IN VIA THE
MODERATE TELEPHONE SERVICE TO
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN ACCESS
CODE. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN ACCESS CODE IS
TWO FOUR. TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AS WELL AS YOUR
TELEPHONE SCREEN. WHAT THEN
MOVE ON TO THE AGENDA FOR A
SCHEDULED HEARING. WE HAVE
SEVEN ITEMS. ON THE AGENDA
AGAIN WITH TWO ITEMS ON CONSENT
WE CURRENTLY LACK OF QUORUM
STILL BE ACTING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. AND WE I UNDERSTAND
THAT- SENATOR ROSS JR WROTE
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ALL THE
BILLS TODAY SO IF WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS SENATE
BILL. SIX ZERO SEVEN PLEASE
PERCENT WHATEVER READY WELCOME
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
SENATE BILL SIX OH SEVEN IS A
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
OMNIBUS BILL CONTAINING SEVERAL
CHANGES TO A NUMBER OF PRACTICE
ACTS ADMINISTERED. BY VARIOUS
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS THE CHANGES
CONTAINED IN THIS BILL STEM
FROM PRIOR SUNSET REVIEW-OVERSIGHT DISCUSSIONS
CONSIDERED NON CONTROVERSIAL.
SUBSTANTIVE CODE CLEANUP.
BASICALLY THE BILL WAVES
INITIAL LICENSING OR
APPLICATION FEES FOR MILITARY
SPOUSES WHOSE APPLICATIONS ARE
ON A FAST TRACK THROUGH AN
EXPEDITED FORMAL PROCESS. IT
ADDS TO THE APPROPRIATE
STATUTORY LANGUAGE FOR THE
ARCHITECTURE BOARD TO RECEIVE
APPLICANT FINGERPRINTS IT
INCREASES THE AMOUNT OF THE
CURRENT CONTRACTORS LICENSE
BOND BY TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND INCREASES THE LICENSING
FEES FOR CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD. ELIMINATES
BARRIERS TO PERFORMING
NECESSARY REPAIRS ON EXTERIOR
ELEVATED ELEMENTS. LIKE
BALCONIES BY CLARIFYING THE
CONTRACTOR CAN INSPECT FOR AND
PERFORM SAFETY ENHANCING
REPAIRS. AND IT UPDATES
PROVISIONS TO REFLECT WHAT THE
DENTAL BOARD COLLECTS FOR PT
PEDIATRIC MINIMAL SEDATION
PERMITS REPEALS THE CLINICAL
AND PRACTICAL EXAMINATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR REGISTERED
DENTAL ASSISTANTS. IN ESSEX
STANDARD FUNCTIONS AND
CLARIFIES THE APPROVAL TIMELINE.
FOR FOREIGN DENTAL SCHOOLS. WE
KNOW OPPOSITION AND AT THE TIME
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. PHONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IT CHAIRMAN RALPH. THIS IS
A JOY TO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE I WOULD
BEGIN WITH ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT LIMITING
YOUR TESTIMONY TO NO MORE THAN
TWO MINUTES. MY WE HAVE ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OF DEVICE IF THERE ARE
ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX ZERO SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NINE ONE THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
TWO FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMEN AND MEMBERS SPREAD
GLAD BUILT THE WITH APEX GROUP
HOME BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SURELY FEDERATION. WE'RE IN
SUPPORT HAVE A WONDERFUL DAY
THANK YOU. NINE THREE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS MY CANNOT KEEP A
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD. THE BOARD IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX AT SEVEN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THAT
CONCLUDES THE PRIMARY WIN THIS
IN SUPPORT AND A FULL POTS FROM
ONE MOMENT TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. LOW HERE FLORA. BERMAN
HELLO CHEN- CHILL CUNNINGHAM
DALY. THE DALLAS. FONG GIPSON
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN RT MEDINA.
MULLIN SALAS. CHANGE WEBER.
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE STAFF
WHICH GIVE ME ONE. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BUT I'M SECTOR
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. AND
THEN WE WERE JUST GETTING TO
MOBILE WE CONCLUDED PRIMARY WIN
THIS. TESTIMONY ON THE PHONES-
SEEING THAT THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL PRIMARY WITNESSES
THAT'S BEGIN TESTIMONY WILL
OPEN UP THE- FORM IN THE
HEARING ROOM FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. IN SUPPORT OPERATOR
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SIGNIFY THEIR- SUPPORT AS
WELL. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX ZERO SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MOMENT WE DO HAVE ONE
NINE. SIX OF THEM IN A FEW
MOMENTS FOR GATHERING THE LINE
NUMBERS ONE MOMENT. JENNIFER.
ONE THREE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. COMBOS.
I LIVE IN LOW LEVEL HARDWARE
CALIFORNIA. AND AYE OPPOSED
THE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WANT TO CLARIFY AGAIN WE'RE
CURRENTLY ON SENATE BILL SIX
ZERO ONE THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO SIGNIFY THEIR SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION FOR THE- PROPER
BILLS AGAIN OPERATE IF YOU
COULD KINDLY OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SIGNIFY
THEIR SUPPORT ON ITS SENATE
BILL. SIX ZERO SEVEN. AND NINE
TO NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
SOPHIA DAMERON RODRIGUEZ I LIVE
IN HOLLISTER CALIFORNIA AYE
OPPOSED SB EIGHT OH THREE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF FOR A
SECOND TIME LET'S ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE COLORS. SIGNIFYING
THEIR SUPPORT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND AGAIN THIS
IS ON SENATE BILL SIX ZERO
SEVEN OPERATOR WOULD YOU KINDLY
OPEN UP THE LINE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC SPECIFICALLY ONLY ON
SENATE BILL SIX ZERO SEVEN. AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND-
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX ZERO SEVEN. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN GENERAL. WE DO
HAVE ONE LINE IN THE QUEUE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. MY TO NINETY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX ZERO
SEVEN. PATTERSON TELEBRANDS THE
NEW PRETTY CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE. SB THREE OH THREE. I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THAT'S GREAT
THANK YOU FOR ADDITIONAL A
FURTHER CLARIFICATION FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. THERE
MIGHT BE SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES ARE DIFFICULTY
UNDERSTANDING DIRECTIONS BUT TO
CLARIFY ONCE MORE ALL WE WILL
BE CALLING FOR THE PROPER TIME
SO IF YOU COULD KINDLY PAY
ATTENTION I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE CLOSE TO A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC CURRENTLY DOT INTO THE
PHONE LINE. ON A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT BILLS SO AT THE
PROPER TIME WILL CALL IN AND-
BUT BIGGER LINES FOR THE
APPROPRIATE BILL TO BE
DISCUSSED. SO HAVING CONCLUDED
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
FOR SENATE BILL SIX ZERO SEVEN
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SIGNIFY
OR SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ON
SENATE BILL SIX ZERO SEVEN
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SIGNIFY
THEIR OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL. SIX ZERO SEVEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX ZERO
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB SIX ZERO SEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
THERE. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
COMMENT IN THE QUEUE WE DO HAVE
ONE COMMENT ONE MOMENT.
GATHERING A LINE NUMBER OF BE
JUST A BRIEF MOMENT. NINE THREE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE FUENTES AND I AM A
STUDENT AT CONFERENCES SO IF
THE TO- OF THE FED EX AND
COSMETOLOGY AND AYE OPPOSED AT
B- SORRY I FORGOT. K. EIGHT OH
THREE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
IS THE WRONG BILL. OPERATOR
WOULD YOU WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT
SOUNDS LIKE THE OPERATOR HAS
SIGNIFIED THAT THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME IT'S
SENATE BILL SIX ZERO SEVEN. SEE
NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE
IN THE GALLERIES OR THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOMS WISHING
TO SIGNIFY THEIR OPPOSITION
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION BY MISTER
GIPSON SECOND BY ASSEMBLY ONE
IRWIN. SENATE ROTH YOU WISH TO
CLOSE SIMPLY AS FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB SIX
ZERO SEVEN MEN TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORA FLORA HI BERMAN.
BERMAN NIGHT BLOOM BLOOM HI
CHEN CHEN HI TO. CUNNINGHAM
DALLI DALLI HI FONG. FONG HI
GIPSON GIPSON HI GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN. IRWIN IRWIN
HI MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN SALAS
SALAS FIGHTING WEBER WEBER HI.
MEDINA MEDINA HIGH. THIRTY NINE
ZERO KNOWS THIRTY NICELY THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS. COLLEAGUES WERE GONNA
MOVE ON TO CONSENT AGAIN THIS
IS ON SENATE BILL EIGHT HUNDRED
AS WELL AS SENATE BILL. EIGHT
TWENTY SIX. GET MOTION BY
MISTER GIVENS TAKEN BY MR SAUCE
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SB EIGHT HUNDRED
ARCHULETA SB EIGHT TO SIX
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORA. FLORA ALL RIGHT
BERMAN. BERMAN HI BLOOM. BLOOM
HI CHEN. CHEN HI CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM DELLY DELLY HI FONG.
FONG HI GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON HI HOLDEN IRWIN-
WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA HI
MULLIN SALAS. SALAS I EIGHTEEN
WEBER WEBER HI. THIRTY NINE
ZERO KNOWS THIRTEEN I BELIEVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE WHICH IS SENATE BILL
EIGHT ZERO ONE UNFEELING ARTS
THE BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES THIS DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES THE I'LL- CARE ROTH.
PLEASE PRESENT WHATEVER READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- LET ME
JUST SAY IT'S THE SUNSET BILL
FOR BOTH THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES AND THE
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND THANK STAFF FOR
THE WORK. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE NUMBER AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE ANY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JERRY ROTH
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES TO EITHER
SIGNIFY THEIR SUPPORT AND ARE
ON HAND FOR ANY TECHNICAL.
QUESTIONS AND OUR ANSWERS
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE UP
THE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL EIGHT ZERO ONE. THE
LINE SAID ANTOINETTE SOREK AND
STEVE SUTTER GOING ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE HI GOOD
AFTERNOON WITH OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND DAD CHAIRMAN LOW
AND MY NAME IS THE INTERNET
STORY CAN END WITH THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT OH ONE AND
I HAVE MY LEADERSHIP TEAM ON
THE LINE IF THERE ARE ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
AB GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIRMAN AND
BOARD MEMBERS- I AM C. THIRTY
GRAND EXECUTIVE OFFICER ABOARD
THE EIGHT YEAR OLD SCIENCES AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF. THE L.
EIGHT OH ONE- AND IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS WE'RE HERE TO
ANSWER THEM THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR AT THE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES THE PRIMARY.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SIGNIFY THEIR SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME ONLY. FOR SENATE BILL
EIGHT ZERO ONE AND IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC. IS
PICKING ON THE WRONG BILL FEEL
FREE TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. EIGHT ZERO ONE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT
ZERO ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. NINE ONE ZERO SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS COLLINS WORSE OF THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION- IN SUPPORT OF THE
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY SUNSET
REVIEW THANKS TO THE COMMITTEE
BOTH SENATE ASSEMBLY FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NINE TO FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS JENNIFER ALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPISTS
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
EXTENSION OF THE ABORTED
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND THE BOARD'S WORK ON ON THAT
SUNSET INFORMATION AND ON THE A
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE RELATED TO
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
SCOPE THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT CONCLUDES THE PRIMARY
TESTIMONY AS WELL AS PUBLIC.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. FOR
SENATE BILL EIGHT TILL ONE.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINE FOR THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHICH IS BEGIN
OPPOSITION ONLY TO SENATE BILL
EIGHT ZERO ONE. THANK YOU
MISTER TURNER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. EIGHT
ZERO ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE EIGHT ZERO
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN.
ZERO WE HAVE NO COMMENTS IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO YOU KNOW
DIGITAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND TERM RUSTY
WHICH TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH JEREMY. COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB EIGHT ZERO ONE ARCHULETA TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORA. FLORA HI BERMAN.
BERMAN HI BLOOM. BLOOM HI CHEN.
CHEN HI CHIU. CUNNINGHAM DALY.
FONG. FONG HI GIPSON GIPSON HI
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA HI MULLIN SALAS SALAS HI
TEAM. WEBER WEBER HI. TWELVE
AYE ZERO KNOWS TELEVISED
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. HI
COMMITTEE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOR THIS IS SB EIGHT
ZERO TWO FOUR PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE. IT
CHEN SENATOR ROTH PLEASE
PROCEED WHENEVER READY THANK
SUNSET BILL FOR THE BUREAU OF
PRIVATE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. AND STEMS FROM OUR
WORK TO COLLECTIVELY DETERMINE
THE BEST PATH FORWARD TO ENSURE.
STUDENT SUCCESS AND QUALITY
EDUCATION WHILE RECOGNIZING THE
NEED FOR APPROPRIATE
TRANSFERRED REGULATIONS OF THE
PROGRAMS OFFERING TRAINING AND
EDUCATION TO MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. JUST QUICKLY TO
HIGHLIGHT WHAT IT DOES. THIS
BILL EXTENDS THE OPERATION OF
THE BUREAU FOR ONE YEAR SO THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE WORKING ON
ISSUES RELATED TO. THE BUREAU'S
SOLVENCY REGULATIONS SPECIALTY
PROGRAMS ENHANCED OVERSIGHT ON
THE FRONT END OF THE LICENSURE
PROCESS AND A HOST OF OTHER
TOPICS AT THE APPROPRIATE POINT
IN TIME I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR OF A- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GENEROSA I UNDERSTAND
THAT WE HAVE DEBBIE COCHRAN AS
A PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
OPPORTUNITY PLEASE UP THE LINES
FOR PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
YES THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CARILLO NUMBER THE COMMITTEE
DEBBIE COCHRAN BEARD CHIEF AT
THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION. DID
NOT HAVE ANY POSITION ON SB
INTERVIEW AT THIS TIME BUT WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
ATTENTION OF SENATE ARE OFTEN
THE COMMITTEE'S THESE ISSUES
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL. ISSUES THAT MAY
ARISE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THAT CONCLUDES OUR
PRIMARY TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES AT THIS MOMENT IN
TIME FOR ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK.
IN SUPPORT ON. SB. EIGHT ZERO
TWO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT ZERO TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT ZERO
TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AND ONE MOMENT FOR FIRST LINE
NUMBER. NINE EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE REGIONAL BLEACHER FROM
NIELSEN MARKS A MARKED IN HERE
REPRESENTING SEVEN
PSYCHOANALYTIC INSTITUTES
ACROSS THE STATE WE SUPPORT AT
THE EIGHT OH TO A COMMENDED. TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS WE HAVE
REGARDING THE IMPACT OF THE
EXTENSION OF THE SUNSET DATE ON
INSTITUTES THAT CURRENTLY HOLDS
THE VERIFICATION OF EXEMPTION
THANK YOU. NINE THREE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT.
WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT UNTIL SHE
GETS AND SEVERAL OF OUR CURRENT
HAVE RECENTLY SUBMITTED A
LETTER OF SUPPORT WE SUPPORT
THE BILL AS AMENDED- WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WOULD FURTHER STRENGTHEN THE
BILL AND HOPE TO SEE THOSE RAIN
NEXT YEAR- MINIMUM OPERATING
STANDARDS- THEY SURE YOU BOB
HARMON TO COVER THE COST OF
UNEXPECTED SCHOOL CLOSURES. I
HAD MORE DISCUSSION ON
INSTITUTIONAL APPROVALS FOR THE
BUREAU BUT SURELY THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS TO ENSURE
THE CONTINUATION OF A
SUFFICIENTLY FUNDED AND STABLE
BUREAU WITH THE CAPACITY AND.
AUTHORITY IT NEEDS TO PROTECT
STUDENT. NOT ONLY BE OFFERED BY
AS COMMITTEE AND I'LL NO BE
ISSUED OF BUREAU FINDING REMAIN
OUT. AND IN NEED A BROKERAGE TO
INSURANCE. AND EFFECTIVE
OVERSIGHT PROGRAM BY THE
BUREAU. RESOLVING THE ISSUE OF
FUNDING IS AS CRITICAL AS THREE
OPERATION AND WE APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFUL PROPOSAL RECENTLY
PUT FORTH BY THE EPA AND THE
BUREAU- WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THE BILL AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT. NINE FOUR TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GOOD SHARE THE BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT. I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT INTO AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT CONCLUDES TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT WILL NOW OPEN UP THE
LINES ARE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SIGNIFY THEIR
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE HELP
THAT THE LINES FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT ZERO TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB EIGHT ZERO TWO YOU MAY PRESS%
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT ZERO
TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
THERE. WE HAVEN'T ARE. SORRY
ONE. COMMENT JUST CAME IN ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE LINE
NUMBER.
NINE FOUR TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JUDITH
ORTEGA. I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES
MY APPROACH SB EIGHT OH THREE.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
THAT CONCLUDES THE PORTION OF
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
CNN THERE'S A GIVE ME SOME
NUMBER TWO. THANK OU MISTER
CHAIR- LET ME FIRST START BY
THANKING THE AUTHOR- AND- I
KNOW THIS IS BEEN A DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION- I DO PLAN TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE TODAY BUT
I WANT TO STATE THAT. GIVEN THE
MANY CHALLENGES THAT I'VE FACED
BPP OVER THE YEARS AND
PARTICULARLY WHAT WE KNOW OF
FROM DISCUSSIONS IN THIS PAST
YEAR I JUST WANT TO EXPRESS. MY
INITIAL HOPE AND FRANKLY SOME
DISAPPOINTMENT THAT WE COULDN'T
INCLUDE SOME OF THE PROPOSALS
THAT WE DISCUSSED AS A BODY
DURING THE MARCH SUNSET REVIEW
HEARING- EARLIER THIS YEAR. NOW
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE- I BELIEVE
THERE WAS AND IS FAIRLY BROAD
CONSENSUS ON A NUMBER OF
CRITICAL ITEMS- FOR MINIMUM
OPERATING STANDARDS TO
PERFORMING APPROVAL BY
ACCREDITATION- THE POTENTIAL
INCLUSION OF A SURETY BOND
REQUIREMENT- AND I HAD HOPED
THAT WE WERE ABOUT TO VOTE ON A
FULL EXTENSION THIS YEAR WITH
THOSE ITEMS. THAT BEING SAID
AGAIN I KNOW HOW CHALLENGING
CENSOR REVIEW IS- FOR THE
BUREAU FOR DCA AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED THIS
PROCESS AND- MY HOPE AND
EXPECTATION IS THAT THIS YEAR
LONG EXTENSION WILL BE USED TO
COME UP WITH A REASONABLE
FUNDING PLAN. I KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN WORKING ON A NEW
PROPOSAL- AND REALLY SOLIDIFY
THE CRITICAL STERN PROTECTIONS
THAT WE ALL WANT TO SEE IN THIS
MEASURE SO I JUST REALLY WANTED
TO SPEAK TO SAY WHILE I SUPPORT
THIS NOT REALLY PUSH AND PROD
ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO WORK AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE- WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE STUDENTS. ARE
ARE BEING SERVED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIMILAR TO A SIMILAR
BERMAN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHARLES ONE A SECOND- THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO- YOU KNOW A LOT
OF THE DEFICIENCIES HAVE BEEN
RESEARCHED AND CHRONICLED AND
DISCUSS- AND I KNOW THAT WE ALL
OF THE YOU KNOW THIS IS A VERY
BUSY YEAR AND MAYBE THERE WAS
ENOUGH BANDWIDTH. TO ADDRESS
ALL THE PROBLEMS OF BPP BUT-
YEAH HOPEFULLY WITH THE NEW
LEADERSHIP THERE AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDING THE
APPROPRIATE GUIDANCE- AND
OVERSIGHT WE CAN REALLY TURN
THAT YOU'RE AROUND- TO PROTECT
THE STUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA-
BECAUSE THAT'S WE'VE BEEN
FEELING AT THAT I THINK I THINK
B. B. E. AS IN FILLING OUT
THAT- FOR SOME TIME NOW AND
IT'S CLEARLY AN AREA OF NEED-
THAT I KNOW I'LL BE VERY
INTERESTED IN AND WATCHING AND
PARTICIPATING IN AS THE
CONVERSATIONS BEFORE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. EMIRATI WISH TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER I JUST WANT TO
STATE THAT I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
ASSEMBLY THE UNFORTUNATE THING
WITH THIS PARTICULAR
SENSIBILITY WILL RECOGNIZE
BECAUSE YOU ARE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. IS THAT THERE ARE
FOR LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEES
INVOLVED IN THIS PARTICULAR
PROCESS AND THE ADMINISTRATION
WE HAVE SERIOUS ISSUES HAVING
TO DO WITH THE FUNDING. OF THE
BUREAU AND HOW THAT SHOULD BE
STRUCTURED WHETHER IT SHOULD BE
DIFFERENT THAN THE NORMAL
BOARDS AND EUROS THAT WE DEAL
WITH IN THESE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE THE BNP COMMITTEES ALONG
WITH ALL OF THE ISSUES YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED AND FRANKLY SOME NEW
ONES. INVOLVING A PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS AND HOW THOSE
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS SHOULD FOLD
INTO THE- OF THE BUREAU'S
PROCESS SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH CARILLO- AS WE
START THIS NEXT YEAR AND WRAP
THIS THING UP IN A MORE ROBUST
FASHION AND ADDRESS THE ISSUES
THAT. THAT YOU BOTH HAVE-
ADDRESS DURING THIS PROCEEDING
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIRMAN ROTH AND TWO
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS ONE OF THAT IS SIMILAR
CHIU AND BERMAN AS WELL AS A
HIRED CHAIRMAN MEDINA HAVE
TAKEN. A SPECIFIC LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE. ON LEGISLATIVE
APPROACHES. BECAUSE OF A
PANDEMIC WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
TACKLE MUCH OF THE SIXTEEN OR
SO PLUS. BOARDS IN BURROWS AT
THIS TIME BUT IT'S OUR DEEP
COMMITMENT AS THE RESPECTIVE
CHAIRS IN BOTH HOUSES. TO IRON
OUT MANY OF THESE ISSUES. AND
PUT THE DUE DILIGENCE THAT IS
NECESSARY TO DO IT RIGHT.
RATHER THAN TRYING TO JAM
SOMETHING IN. WITHOUT THE FULL
TYPE OF DIALOGUE THAT WE KNOW
THAT WE WOULD. ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON AS WELL
SO IT'S OUR DEEP COMMITMENT AS
BOTH CHAIRS. AND THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY TO ALSO INCLUDE YOUR
ENGAGEMENT AS WELL. WITH THAT
SAID THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND
A SECOND COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB EIGHT
ZERO TWO ROTH TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORA. FLORA ALL RIGHT
BERMAN. BERMAN NIGHT BLOOM.
BLOOM HI CHAN. CHAN HI CHU. CHU
AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM HI
DALLI. DELHI HI FONG. FONG HI
GIPSON GIPSON GRAYSON GRAYSON
HI HOLDEN. IRWIN IRWIN HI
MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA HI
MULLIN SALAS SALAS I CAME WEBER
WEBER HI. FIFTEEN AYE ZERO
KNOWS FIFTEEN EYES WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS. BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON THEN TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE THIS IS SB EIGHT
ZERO THREE AGAIN FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. S. B. EIGHT ZERO
THREE ON BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY A JUST AS A
REMINDER OF FOR THOSE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
COMMENT. ON SB EIGHT ZERO THREE
PLEASE BE SURE YOU HAVE DIALED
IN. AND FOLLOW THE MODERATOR
INSTRUCTIONS WE HAVE A TIME
LIMIT OF TWO MINUTES PER. KEY
WITNESS AS WELL AS A TWENTY
MINUTES TOTAL FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SIMPLY
SIGNIFIED THEIR NAME. AND
POSITION AGAIN SIMPLY
SIGNIFYING THEIR NAME AND
POSITION. WITH THOSE
INSTRUCTIONS OUT OF THE WAY
SENATOR RUSS PLEASE PRESENT
WHATEVER READY. THANK YOU CHAIR
THIS IS IN FACT THE SUNSET BILL
THAT MANY HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR.
IT'S THE BILL HAVING TO DO WITH
THE BOARD OF BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY IN THE NEXT CHANGES
STEMMING FROM FRANKLY THE YEARS
LONG SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT
EFFORTS. FOR THE BOARD THAT
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE HAVE
ENGAGED IN. THE GOAL HAS BEEN
AND CONTINUES TO BE FRANKLY TO
BALANCE ECONOMIC MOBILITY AND
EFFORTS TOWARD PROFESSIONALISM
AMONG THE PERSONAL PARENTS
PROFESSIONALS WITH THE
NECESSARY ROLE THAT THE STATE.
MUST PLAY IN MANDATING TRAINING
HOURS AND REQUIRING APPROVAL
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO PROVIDE.
BEAUTIFICATION SERVICES IN
SHORT TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE PROPERLY
TRAINED PROPERLY TRAINED TO
ENSURE. THE PROTECTION OF
CONSUMERS WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME THAT WE ELIMINATE
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT IN THE STATE FOR OUR
STATE RESIDENTS. THIS BILL
UPDATES THE BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY ACT TO REFLECT
CHANGES IN THE BEAUTIFICATION
SERVICES INDUSTRY OVER THE PAST
NUMBER OF YEARS BY MODERNIZING
THE LAW TO BETTER REFLECT
NECESSARY REGULATION FOR
SERVICES. THAT MAKE CARRY A
RISK TO THE CONSUMER AND ALSO
TO THE ARTIST PROVIDING THOSE
SERVICES. THE BILL PROVIDES OUR
STATE'S PERSONAL APPEARANCE
ARTISTS AND PROFESSIONALS WITH
THE FLEXIBILITY TO GET TO WORK
QUICKLY. DOING THEIR CRAFT WITH
APPROPRIATE RELEVANT TRAINING
AND A CONTINUED FOCUS ON SAFETY.
NOW LICENSING REQUIREMENTS ARE
NECESSARY TO PROMOTE SAFETY AND
PROFESSIONALISM AND THIS BILL
STREAMLINES THE PROCESS THAT
APPEARANCE PROFESSIONALS MUST
UNDERGO IN OTHER WORDS
TRAINING. THEY MUST UNDERGO IN
ORDER TO LEGALLY PROVIDE
BEAUTIFICATION SERVICES IN THE
STATE. BY REDUCING THE REQUIRED
NUMBER OF HOURS THE REQUIRED
NUMBER OF HOURS FOR BARBERS AND
COSMETOLOGISTS FROM FIFTEEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS RESPECTIVELY TWO ONE
THOUSAND HOURS. AND THROUGH
AMENDMENTS BY REGULATING HERE
ONLY SERVICES AND REQUIRING
TRAINING NOT LESS THAN SIX
HUNDRED HOURS. THE CHANGES
RELATED TO THE PRACTICAL
EXAMINATION ARE INTENDED TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
PERSONAL APPEARANCE
PROFESSIONALS. DEMONSTRATE
COMPETENCY COMPETENCY IN THE
CURRENT ASPECTS OF THEIR
PRACTICE AND THAT THEY DO SO
DURING THE COURSE. OF THE
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT THEY
UNDERGO. NOW I MUST SAY THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY MANY
MISCONCEPTIONS AND MYTHS ABOUT
THIS BILL THAT I'VE READ ABOUT
IN THE NEWSPAPERS AND LISTEN TO
ON THE RADIO AND THE
TELEVISION. AND THOSE QUITE
FRANKLY ARE IN FACT
MISCONCEPTIONS BILLS NOT
SPONSORED BY CORPORATIONS THAT
COME FROM THE SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS AND THE OVERSIGHT OF
THE BOARD BY THIS LEGISLATURE
THE BILL DOES NOT PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM BEING INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AND AS THEY CAN DO
TODAY. IT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH LABOR TAX OR WAGE RULES
THE BOARD OF BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY HAS NO ROLE IN
WAGING LABOR CLASSIFICATION
FORM ONE FORSMAN IT IS NOT PLAY
A ROLE IN ENSURING THAT PEOPLE
FOLLOW THE LAW AND PAY TAXES.
THE BILL WILL NOT CAUSE MORE
PEOPLE TO GET INFECTIONS AND BE
AND BE HARMED IN FACT THE BILL
INCREASES THE NUMBER OF HOURS
IN INFECTION CONTROL AND
DISINFECTANT AND SANITATION.
TRAINING AND THE BILL WILL NOT
FOR SALONS TO CLOSE. WE ALL
KNOW. MANY OF US IN THIS ROOM.
THAT WE TREASURE OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR HAIR
STYLIST IN THIS BILL DOES NOT.
CHANGE THAT. THE BILL WILL
STILL ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
LEARN SAFELY AND SAFETY
NECESSARY TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
AND THEIR CLIENTS. ONE THOUSAND
HOURS OF SCHOOL IS REQUIRED IN
MANY STATES. VERMONT TEXAS
RHODE ISLAND REQUIRES SIX
HUNDRED HOURS. AND ALLOWS THE
PROFESSIONALISM AND SAFETY
LEARN IN SCHOOL TO STILL BE
ACQUIRED IN THAT STATE AND THAT
IS EXACTLY WHAT WILL BE
REQUIRED HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I AM HAPPY TO
ACCEPT ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS
LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS. AND
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTNERSHIP
SURE LOW AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES NOT
ONLY TODAY. BUT OVER THE NEXT
SIX TO EIGHT WEEKS INCLUDING.
FURTHER CLARIFYING THAT BOARD
LICENSEES ARE NOT MASSAGE
THERAPISTS. AUTHORIZING STUDENT
EXPERIENCE TO GET PAID AND
PARTICIPATE IN THAT PROGRAM FOR
UP TO TWENTY FIVE HOURS PER
WEEK. AFTER COMPLETING ONLY 25%
OF COURSE INSTRUCTION WHICH OF
COURSE IS DOWN FROM THE SIXTY
PERCENT. THE CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES. FOLLOWING THE LEAD IN
THE GOOD WORK OF YOUR COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON.
FINALLY RESPONDING THE
LICENSEES FROM THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ABOUT CONCERNS THAT HER
CUTTING SHOULD REMAIN LICENSE.
AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THESE
AMENDMENTS TO. IN THIS BILL. AT
THE APPROPRIATE POINT IN TIME
SURE I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
JIM AND ROTH AND FOR ALSO
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
MAINTENANCE. WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT
OF A LIMIT THAT TESTIMONY TO
MANAGE PER INDIVIDUAL. OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR THE PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT LIMITING TO NO MORE
THAN TWO MINUTES PER PERSON. MR
COCHRAN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SORRY A MISS
UNDER WOULD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHRISTIE UNDER WHAT
WHAT THE BOARD OF BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR ROCK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW AND THEIR STAFF ARE WORKING
ON THIS BILL OUR BOARD HAS
TAKEN A POSITION AT THE PORT
WITH AMENDMENTS THOSE
AMENDMENTS HAVE ALL BEEN
ADDRESSED TODAY IN THE ANALYSIS
AND I'M HAPPY TO STAY ON ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT
NEEDED. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL PRIMARY WITNESS
SINCE THE AND SUPPORT I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A-
TARA CRAWFORD GONZALEZ. I WHAT
OKAY AND I AM A LICENSED
COSMETOLOGIST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I AM AN EDUCATOR
FIRST PART THE SECOND I AM A
SUPPORT SB EIGHT ZERO THREE AND
JUST MY PERSONAL TESTIMONY I
WAS A YOUNG MOM AND IT'D TAKE
ME. A MOMENT OVER FAN OF FR
YEARS THE FINANCIAL BURDEN OF
ATTENDING SCHOOL AND HAVING TO
CARE FOR- MY CHILDREN. I
BELIEVE WE SHOULD THE REQUIRED
HOURS YOU'LL HEAR- GRADUATION
NUMBER AND A HIGHER NUMBER F
ENROLLEES IT WAS NOT UNCOMMON-
AT THE TIME OF MY INVOLVEMENT.
THE STUDENT COMES OUT WITHOUT
COMPLETING. ALL FIELD
TECHNIQUES ARE LEARNED ON THE
JOB THEY'RE NOT BE FULL.
OCCUPATION OF GREATLY POT BUT
JUST BEING ON THE TRAINING SIDE
AS I SEE NEARLY LIKE THE PILOT
STRUGGLE WITH THEIR TECHNICAL
SKILLS. AND WE SHOULD GIVE OUR
NEW LIKE COGNOMEN BARBERS
OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCESSFUL AND
GET INTO THE WORKFORCE MUCH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT CONCLUDES OUR TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OPERATOR
WILL PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES
NOW FOR ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC QUESTION TO
SIMPLY SIGNIFIED THEIR SUPPORT
WITH NAME AND POSITION ON
SENATE BILL EIGHT ZERO THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. EIGHT ZERO THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WHICH AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK. OF SB EIGHT ZERO
THREE PRESS ONE. ZERO ONE
MOMENT PLEASE YOU HAVE AN ECHO
ON.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND THE ECHO HAS BEEN RESOLVED.
AND JUST A BRIEF MOMENT. MY TWO
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DON'T I'M
NOT SURE TWENTY SEVENTY FIVE MY
NAME IS RANDY PRESENT NINE IN
SUPPORT. OF THE BILL SB. EIGHT
AGREE. MY TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IN HUMANITY
HERE- ON BEHALF OF THE FUTURE
OF THE BEAUTY INDUSTRY
COALITION IN SUPPORT. GET OUT
ON THE MORE THAN NINE TO EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS BERNADETTE
FOOTBALL I THINK THAT THE
PATIENT AND HELP THEM GROW AND
I SUPPORT IT THE EIGHT ZERO
THREE. MY TWO THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS CHERYL CAPITAL
MELLIE AND I'M LICENSE IN LOS
ANGELES AS AN ESTHETICIAN AND I
SUPPORT S. B. EIGHT OH THREE
AMENDED. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LAST MINUTE I'M A LICENSED
ESTHETICIAN AND I SUPPORT SB.
EIGHT OH THREE IF AMENDED I'M
LOCATED IN FAIRFIELD. NINE
THREE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MULLIN
RUNNING THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE
BURKE AND THANK YOU FOR THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER FOR US
TODAY- I'M AN ESTHETICIAN AND
ALSO AN INSTRUCTOR IN ORANGE
COUNTY. THE ARMENIAN. EIGHT OF.
THREE NINE THREE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK HI YES MY NAME IS JULIA
HEY I AM AN ESTHETICIAN IN
MANTECA AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
AT THE EIGHT OH THREE WITH
AMENDED. MY THREE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ANGELA
BLACK I AM A LICENSED
ESTHETICIAN AND LOS ANGELES AND
I WORK AT THE EIGHT OH THREE.
NINE THREE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ANNIE HALL AND
I'M A LICENSED ESTHETICIAN AND
GATE OWNER IN CLOVER CALIFORNIA
AND I SUPPORT SB EIGHT OH
THREE. NINE THREE SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS YOLANDA
MORROW I AM A LICENSED
ESTHETICIAN IN FULTON
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT SB
EIGHT OH THREE WITH AMENDMENT
THANK YOU. NINE TWO FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS LAURA
HAMILTON THE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS DIRECTOR FOR
ASSOCIATED SKIN CARE
PROFESSIONALS ASSOCIATED HER
PROFESSIONALS ASSOCIATED NOW
PROFESSIONALS AND WE SUPPORT. A
SENATE BILL EIGHT OH THREE
THANK YOU. NINE ONE TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS CHEYENNE. AND I'M
LOCATED IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA NINE IN SUPPORT OF
THE EIGHT OH THREE. NINE ONE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TRACY
BALL I'M A LICENSED ESTHETICIAN
AND WONDERING THE CALIFORNIA
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL EIGHT OH THREE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU. NINE THREE SEVENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
INTRIGUED BY THOSE I'M NOT
LIKELY THAT THE PRESIDENT
SACRAMENTO AND I SUPPORT ITO'S
THREE THANK YOU. NINE THREE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JOSE NOT A LICENSED BARBER IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND I SUPPORT
EIGHT OH THREE IF AMEND IT THE
RIGHT WAY- NOT COMPLETELY DOING
AWAY WITH IT BUT AT LEAST
MINIMIZED OURS SO WE CAN
GRADUATE AND- GET TO WORK NORTH.
MY THREE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S KENYA BARBER I'M A
LICENSED ESTHETICIAN AND DURING
THE MONICA AND I DO SUPPORT THE
BILL EIGHT OH THREE IF AMENDED
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NINE FOUR
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
MARYLAND BY THEIR LICENSE AND
PUBLIC COLLEGES I OPPOSE SB.
EIGHT OH THREE. NINE FOUR OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO YES YOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
GEORGE ARE YOU LEAVING
SOUTHGATE I'M HIGHLIGHTS THE
COSMETOLOGIST I'M NOT OPPOSED
IT BE A ROOKIE. THANK YOU. NINE
FOUR THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NOT THE
CONTROLLER AND I WILL POST
COULD THAT BE. EIGHT THREE.
THANK YOU JUST A REMINDER WERE
CURRENTLY ON SUPPORT AT THIS
MOMENT IN TIME SO AGAIN JUST
SIMPLY SUPPORT. AND ONE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS JANE
NELSON I'M A LICENSED
ESTHETICIAN IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT AT THE
END OF THREE AMENDED THANK YOU.
NINE THREE ZERO SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
ANDY DRAMATIC OFTEN IN POWAY
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT I'M A
LICENSED ESTHETICIAN I SUPPORT.
SB EIGHT OH THREE IMPLEMENTED
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS SANDRA
PALOMINO I AM A LICENSED
ESTHETICIAN IN PALM SPRINGS
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT SB
EIGHT OH THREE AMENDED THANK
YOU. NINE FOUR TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BEFORE TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS ERIN SANDBOX I AM A
LICENSED ESTHETICIAN HERE IN
MERRITT ISLAND FLA HOW
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT SB
EIGHT OH THREE GET AMENDED. MY
FOR FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ONE OF FLORIDA'S I'M CALM WITH
A CALIFORNIA AND AYE OPPOSED TO
AT THE AGE OF THREE. THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS BRIDGET BROWN AND DOES
NOT BORN YET I'M LIKE THAT. I
WORK AT. EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
THREE. NINE ONE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS VICTORIA
CRICKETER I AM A LICENSED
ESTHETICIAN IN MODESTO
CALIFORNIA I TO COURT AT THE
GROCERY WITH AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU SO MUCH. NINE ONE EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE EVERYONE MY NAME IS
TATIANA SIMONIAN I AM A
LICENSED ESTHETICIAN IN ORANGE
COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT. SB EIGHT OH THREE IF
AMENDED THANK YOU. NINE TWO
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. L. L. AND
STACEY WEST BURKE AND I SUPPORT
SB EIGHTY THREE AT THE MOMENT
THANK YOU. NINE THREE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MOLLY YOU
CAN ON A LIGHT EXPEDITION IN
CHICO CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
AT THE AGE OF THREE IS AMENDED
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR OH TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MELINA
VARGAS I AM A LICENSED
ESTHETICIAN. SB EIGHT OH THREE
IF AMENDED THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
SERRA CONDO I AM A LICENSED
ESTHETICIAN IN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT SB
EIGHT OH THREE IF AMENDED THANK
YOU. FINE FOR EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SH HELLO MY NAME IS BRITNEY
PURCELL AND MY NAME IS REBECCA
MARTIN AND WE ARE LICENSED
ESTHETICIANS IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT SB
EIGHT ZERO THREE IF AMENDED
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JODY SITES I'M A
LICENSED ESTHETICIAN NOW GROVE
CALIFORNIA LIKELY SUPPORT SB
EIGHT OH THREE OF THEM AND IT
THANK YOU. NINE FIVE OH TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS LAURIE ROBERTS AND I'M
AT STATE BOB OWNER AND AN
APPLICATION AND LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND I FULLY SUPPORT
SB EIGHT OH THREE WITH
AMENDMENT. NINE EIGHTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI SORRY I'M KIMBERLY FRANCE
FROM WESTLAKE VILLAGE
CALIFORNIA LICENSE COSMETOLOGY.
AB I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB BE
EIGHT OH THREE. MY NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM TRULY SEE A TIME
LINE ON THE LICENSE APPLICATION
AND ESTHETICS INSTRUCTOR IN LOS
ANGELES AND I'M SUPPORT SB
EIGHTY EIGHT OH THREE WEST
AMENDMENT. MARTINEZ YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
ONE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISS
MARTINEZ. ME MOVING ON TO LINE
ONE OH THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ALEXIS FIVE AND I AM A LICENSED
ESTHETICIAN IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I FULLY SUPPORT
SB EIGHT OH THREE THANK YOU.
LINE ONE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS KAREN I THINK I THINK I'M A
LICENSED ESTHETICIAN IN
MODERATE- I PHONE SUPPORT SB
EIGHT INSURANCE. BUT IN MY MIND
TO. NINE TO EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS MICHELLE FITZPATRICK
I'M A LICENSED ESTHETICIAN IN
ROCKLAND AND I SUPPORT SB EIGHT
OH THREE WITH THE AMENDMENT.
NINE THREE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU.
NINE THREE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SONYA KING I AM A
LICENSED ESTHETICIAN IN LOS
ANGELES AND I SUPPORT AT THE
END OF THREE S. THANK YOU. NINE
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M SORRY NINE FOUR
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LEVEES FOR A LOAN FROM LOS
ANGELES I OPPOSED. TO SB. EIGHT
OH THREE. MY FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MELANIE
BROWN SO AS TO SUPPLY TEMP AT
THE POOR S. B. EIGHT OH THREE
AS AMENDED. MY FIVE OH FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KELLY
POINTS IN LIFE AND CLOSE
CALIFORNIA AND- I AM IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT OH THREE WITH THE
MAN THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME CLAPPING
SHEA AND I'M A LICENSED
COSMETOLOGIST IN CALIFORNIA AND
I'M DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT OH THREE AND THE
REDUCTION OF OURS I THE
REMOVAL OF THE PRACTICAL EXAM
THANK YOU. NINE ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO YES YOUR LINE
IS OPEN HI THANK YOU- HI MY
NAME IS BARBARA MONTAGNE AND I
AM CALLING FROM MISSION VIEJO
CALIFORNIA IN A SUPPORT. EIGHTY
EIGHT ZERO THREE. MY FIVE OH
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO BYE BYE YES
YEAH HI MY NAME IS AMANDA LAMB
AND I'M SORRY I'M ACTUALLY I'M
A WHOLE NEW SB. EIGHT OH THREE.
THANK YOU NINE FIVE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL WON'T WORK
I'M A LICENSED COSMETOLOGIST
AND A PARTNERSHIP OWNER AND I
OPPOSE S. B. NO THREE. MINDFUL
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO YES YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
LAURIE CREATING AND I'M A
LICENSED COSMETOLOGIST OUT OF
IN LOVE CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT
EIGHT SB EIGHT OH THREE AS WELL
AS THE AMENDMENT. THANK YOU.
NINE FIVE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME AT THE END OF THIS BUT I
AM A LICENSED ESTHETICIAN FROM
ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT AT
B. EIGHT OH THREE AT THE MINUTE
THANK YOU. NINE THREE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THREE EIGHTY
NINETY MAYBE A NEW YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE FIVE SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'VE BEEN TWO FIVE SIX PM YES
MY- YEAH IT IF NAME IS KAREN
GRANT BE DETECTED. LOW
COSMETOLOGIST AND IT TO. AND I
HOPE TO S. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES THE- WITNESSES TO
SIGNIFY THEIR SUPPORT ON THE
PHONES LET'S TRN TO THE
CHAMBERS HERE IN THE GALLERIES
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
SIMPLY WISHING TO SIGNIFY THEIR
SUPPORT. BY STATING THEIR NAME
AND POSITION WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WENDY
COCHRAN FOUNDER OF CALIFORNIA
STATIC ALLIANCE ON BEHALF OF
NINETY THOUSAND LICENSED
ESTHETICIANS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY. SUPPORT
SB EIGHT OH THREE READING THE
AMENDMENTS BRINGING EVERYTHING
BACK INTO REGULATION. GOOD
AFTERNOON JAMIE SHOT BACK
LICENSE MANICURIST AND OWNER OF
PRECISION NAILS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SIGNIFY THE
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS. SCENE ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SIGNIFY THE SUPPORT. THAT
CONCLUDES THE PORTION OF THE
MEETING FOR PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION I WOULD BEGIN WITH
OPPOSITION- WITH THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
FOLLOWED BY. IN PERSON.
OPPOSITION OF ALL THEN BY
OPPOSITION ON THE TELEPHONE
LINE SO OPERATOR WHICH WE
PLEASE GO TO THE- PRIMARY TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WILL
ALSO LIMIT YOUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES FOR THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
LINES. PARDON ME ASSURE I ONLY
SHOW THE TWO WITNESSES IN
PERSON. OKAY OKAY GO TO THE TO
BEAR WITH THIS IS IT IN PERSON
PLEASE- YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
AND NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES
WELCOME THANK YOU. I AM GOING
TO SETTING ALSO I AM THE
FOUNDER OF BARBERS ASIDE WITH
OVER FORTY THOUSAND MEMBERS I'M
A BARBER SHOP OWNER IN AN
INDUSTRY ORGANIZER FROM LOS
ANGELES AS YOU HEARD US
ADDITIONS ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT OR THREE BECAUSE IT
STRENGTHENS OUR LICENSE AND
SCOPE OF PRACTICE. BUT LET'S
TALK ABOUT WHAT IT DOES TO THE
BARBER AND COSMETOLOGIST AS
VITA THREE PRESENTS ITSELF AS
WELL INTENTIONED SUGGESTING THE
BARRIER OF ENTRY INTO THE
BEAUTY PROFESSION BE LOWERED
AND MADE MORE ACCESSIBLE TO
INDIVIDUALS WANTING TO ENSURE
THE TRAIT WHICH RAISE THE
QUESTION WHAT INDUSTRY DO THESE
FUTURE PROFESSIONALS. BE
ENTERING A HUNDRED YEARS AGO
TRADESPEOPLE IN THIS PROFESSION
ORGANIZED CREATING EDUCATION
REGULATION LICENSING AND
STANDARDS TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
AND WORKERS THIS INDUSTRIES
MAJORITY SMALL BUSINESSES OWNED
AND OPERATED BY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THAT INCLUDE PEOPLE
OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS WOMEN
VETERANS AND LGBT Q. PLUS. FOR
OVER A CENTURY HAS ALLOWED US
TO HAVE OWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES
THAT TRANSLATE TO EQUITY IN THE
MARKET THE CORPORATIONS AND
BILLIONAIRES SUPPORTING THIS
BILL WILL SLOWLY TAKE THAT AWAY
FROM MICRO SMALL BUSINESSES AND
SMALL BUSINESSES AS A TAKE OVER
A LARGER PART OF OUR MARKET
SHARE. BY SUPPORTING
REGULATIONS A LOWER HOURS IN
TRAINING THIS NOT ONLY
DIMINISHES OUR PROFESSIONALISM
BUT COMPROMISES OUR LIVELIHOODS
THE COMPANIES BEHIND. THIS BILL
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. ONLY
HAVE ONE GOAL IN MIND AND
THAT'S TO MASS PRODUCE
TECHNICIANS TO FILL THEIR SHOPS
THAT STRUGGLE TO RETAIN
PROFESSIONALS CURRENTLY. THE
NUMBER ONE REASON WHY
PROFESSIONALS DON'T WANT TO
WORK FOR CORPORATIONS IS THAT
THEY'RE LIMITED IN IN IN THE
EARNING POTENTIAL. THEY WORK
FOR A SYSTEM THAT TAKES FIFTY
TO SIXTY. OF THEIR EARNINGS IN
ADDITION TO STATE AND FEDERAL
TAXATION CORPORATION
SUPPORTING. LOWER TO LOWER THE
BARRIERS OF ENTRY WILL ALLOW
THEM TO HAVE. A BIGGER POOL OF
EMPLOYEES TO HIRE. BUT WHAT
THEY FAIL TO THINK ABOUT IS
WHAT IT WILL DO TO THE FUTURE
OF OUR PROFESSION. WE SAW WAS
STARBUCKS DID TO THE LOCAL
COFFEE SHOP. WHAT AMAZON DID TO
THE LOCAL BOOKSTORE AND NOW
WE'RE ASKING FOR THE SAME THING
TO NOT. BE DONE TO LOCAL SALONS
AND BARBERSHOPS. TO SOME THIS
GRASS. THIS CRAFT HAS BEEN
PASSED DOWN FROM GENERATION TO
GENERATION. FOR OTHERS WILL
COME FROM TOUGH BACKGROUNDS
THIS WAS THEIR ONLY SHOT TO
MAKE SOMETHING OF THEMSELVES.
NO MATTER HOW WE GOT HERE WE
ALL SHARE THE SAME LOVE
GRATITUDE AND ADMIRATION FOR
TRADE. AND WHAT THE FUTURE OF
OUR INDUSTRY TO CONTINUE TO
BENEFIT FROM THE WORK LAID OUT
BY OUR PREDECESSORS. AND ENSURE
THAT THE MAJORITY OF THE MARKET
SHARE BE TAKEN UP BY THE PEOPLE
WHO TRULY MAKE UP THIS
BEAUTIFUL INDUSTRY. AND NOT BE
HANDED OVER TO A HANDFUL OF
BILLIONAIRES. SO I ASK YOU
TODAY PUBLIC SERVANTS AND
OFFICIALS TO LOOK BEYOND THE
INTERESTS OF CORPORATIONS WHO
ALREADY HAVE A LOT AND ARE
TRYING TO GET MORE. GET AND
LOOK AFTER THE LIVELIHOODS OF
YOUR CONSTITUENTS. AYE OPPOSED.
SB ZERO THREE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WELL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE FINAL PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION CHRIS TELL US IF YOU
GET A MAJOR TEST MY TO NO MORE
THAN TWO MINUTES WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M CHRIS TELUS
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF BARBERING
AND COSMETOLOGY I'M HERE
REPRESENTING SEVERAL THOUSAND
BARBERSHOPS SALONS IN OVER TWO
HUNDRED FORTY VOCATIONAL
SCHOOLS THAT OVERWHELMINGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
INDUSTRY IS PRIMARILY COMPOSED
OF INDEPENDENT WORKERS WORKERS
WHO CAN MOVE FREELY BETWEEN
JOBS RENT A CHAIR OR OPEN A
SALON BEAUTY SERVICES PEPSI
HISTORICALLY BEEN A SANCTUARY
FOR WOMEN PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY ALLOWING THEM TO
PROSPER IN A WORLD THAT HAS
PROVIDED FEW OPPORTUNITIES AND
MANY IMPEDIMENTS. THIS IS
BECAUSE IN BEAUTY SERVICES
THERE IS NO ESTABLISHED
HIERARCHY TO HOLD YOU BACK.
HOWEVER AS IT INDEPENDENT
DISAGGREGATED WORKFORCE THERE
IS NO OPPORTUNITY FOR BEAUTY
SERVICE PROFESSIONALS TO
UNIONIZE. THE FULL TRAINING AND
LICENSE THEREFORE IS A FORM OF
UNIONIZATION PROVIDING
PROTECTION. FOR THESE
PROFESSIONALS SO THAT THEY CAN
MAKE GOOD WAGES AND MOVE UP THE
ECONOMIC LADDER. LAST WEEK I UP
LOADED FOR YOUR PACKET THE
HIGHLY REGARDED TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN STUDY FROM THE
NATIONAL BUREAU OF ECONOMIC
RESEARCH BY PETER BLAIR OF
HARVARD. AND BOBBY JOHN FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO WHICH
CONFIRMED THAT OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING REDUCES THE RACIAL
PAY GAP BY UP TO FORTY THREE
PERCENT. THE MISSION OF THIS
STUDY BY STAFF UNDERLIES THE
APPALLING LACK OF DATA OR
CONSTITUENT CONSULT
CONSULTATION BEHIND THIS LATE.
THIS LEGISLATION. EIGHTY THREE
CALLS FOR REDUCING THE HOURS
REQUIRED TO GET A LICENSE BUT
IF THE YOU LOWER THE HOURS WHAT
YOU ACTUALLY GET IS A FLOOD.
DRIVING DOWN WAGES FOR AN
ALREADY EMBATTLED POPULATION.
AND ONCE AGAIN YOU HAVE A CASE
WHERE ENTITLED ELITE ATTEMPTS
TO IMPOSE REFORMS ON A MINORITY
POPULATION THAT WAS NOT
CONSULTED AND DOES NOT WANT IT.
IT IS YET ANOTHER TIME ONE CASE
OF WE KNOW WHAT'S BEST FOR YOU.
IT IS PATRONIZING AND INSULTING
TO THE HARD WORKING ESTABLISHED
PROFESSIONALS IN THIS INDUSTRY.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATOR IS BASED ON EMOTION
AND STEREOTYPES NOT RESEARCH OR
REASON. WORST OF ALL YOU HAVE A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE WITH ADVANCED
DEGREES TELLING WOMEN AND
MINORITIES THAT THE BARRIER TO
EMPLOYMENT IS TOO MUCH
EDUCATION. UNBELIEVABLE WHAT IS
GOING ON HERE WHERE IS THE
SCIENCE THIS WILL DUMB DOWN THE
TRAINING AND DRIVE DOWN WAGES
ONLY FOUR STATES OUT OF FIFTY
ONE HAVE A THOUSAND OUR
PROGRAMS AND THOSE FOUR DO NOT
HAVE THE MULTI CULTURAL
POPULATION. OF CALIFORNIA. NOW
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT THE
INDUSTRY THE REGULATIONS AND
THE CURRICULUM NEED REFORM WE
SEE THAT. WE WANT TO BE
INVOLVED IN IT BUT THIS IS NOT
THE BILL. THIS BILL WILL
BACKFIRE ON ITS OWN INTENTIONS
SO WE ASK YOU TO TABLE SB EIGHT
OH THREE. AND ALLOW FOR
FURTHERS FURTHER STUDY. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU STOP
THIS BILL AND ALLOW US TO WORK
TOGETHER TO CRAFT MEANINGFUL
REFORM LEGISLATION. AGAIN WE
WANT YOU TO BE OUR HEROES WE
NEEDED WORK WITH US NOT AGAINST
US. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR- PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE PORTION OF THE MEETING FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
SIGNIFY THEIR OPPOSITION HERE
IN THE CHAMBERS AND IN THE
GALLERY. IF YOU KILEY JUST
REMEMBER NIGHT OUT THE PORTION
WE'RE JUST SIMPLY STATE YOUR
NAME. AFFILIATION AND POSITION.
PLEASE FOR THAT WHATEVER READY.
MONOCHROME THIS SEND ROBO CALLS
WE OPPOSE ETAL THREE. RUN THE
ARNOLD MODESTO CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE SB EIGHT OH THREE.
SHUCKS ANNA SANCHES JASPER
CALIFORNIA PULLS IS V. EIGHT R.
THREE. DINA OUSLEY LOS ANGELES
I OPPOSE SB EIGHT OH THREE.
LILIANA LUCAS SACRAMENTO I
OPPOSE SB EIGHT OH THREE. LAURA
SMITH DO A LICENSE I OPPOSE SB
EIGHT OH THREE. HEATHER KANE
SACRAMENTO DUAL LICENSE I
OPPOSE SB EIGHT OH THREE.
RADIATE SACRAMENTO OPPOSE AS
PETER THREE. ELISEO ORTEGA
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA. ASHLEY
HERNANDEZ SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
I OPPOSE. AUGUSTINE HERNANDO'S
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AYE
OPPOSED ISRAEL DURING. JULIE
LANDAU'S LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
I OPPOSE SB. EIGHT OH THREE.
MUDDY UP THAT IS SAUDI ARABIA
LOS ANGELES. DOUGLAS
CHRISTIANSEN TRUCKEE CALIFORNIA
I OPPOSE SB. EIGHT OH THREE.
SEKAR CAMPBELL MODESTO
CALIFORNIA AYE OPPOSED SB.
EIGHT OH THREE. DECEMBER I
OPPOSE SB EIGHT OH THREE. PAUL
MANTILLA PAUL MITCHELL SCHOOLS
LOS ANGELES OPPOSED. BEATRICE
VELASQUEZ I OPPOSED SB EIGHT OH
THREE. HOW MANY SCOTT LICENSED
COSMETOLOGIST INSTRUCTOR I POSE
AS THE EIGHT OH THREE. VICTORIA
FAMILY MODESTO CALIFORNIA AYE
OPPOSED SB EIGHT OH THREE. EVA
OF RACISM FROM RISA CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE AS FEAR. THREE STEPHANIE
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE SB.
EIGHT OH THREE. ANGELICA
MARTINEZ SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
I OPPOSE SBOP. KADIAN RANDALL
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AYE
OPPOSED SB EIGHT OH THREE.
DEVENU IN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
AYE OPPOSED SB THREE. HALEY
HUGHES MODESTO CALIFORNIA
LICENSED COSMETOLOGIST OPPOSED
EIGHT- THREE. SUSAN GARRETT
MODESTO CALIFORNIA AYE OPPOSED
SB EIGHT OH THREE. TOTTENHAM
OCCURS AS SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
I OPPOSE I SPEED OF THREE.
DANIELLE CHURCH SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE AS PETER.
THREE KATIE SHE WANT MODESTO I
OPPOSE. GEN I KEY IS MODESTO I
OPPOSE. SAID A GREAT MODESTO I
OPPOSE. HAYLIE SANTOS MODESTO I
OPPOSE. HOLLY PACKET VOLCANO
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE A SPEEDO
THREE- MORE YANG SACRAMENTO I
OPPOSE. HORIZONT SACRAMENTO I
OPPOSE. MAURIER RUPERT'S
SACRAMENTO I OPPOSE. MIKE
CRAVEN STARTING CALIFORNIA AYE
OPPOSED SB EIGHT OR THREE.
AMANDA PASSER STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE SB. EIGHT
OH THREE. MICHELLE DC LICENSED
COSMETOLOGIST I OPPOSED SB.
EIGHT OH THREE. ANGELIQUE'S
ANTON AS THE LICENSE BARBER AND
COSMETOLOGIST STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA AYE OPPOSED SB EIGHT
OH THREE. ADRIAN REGO STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE SB.
EIGHT OH THREE. DIMITRIS
SANCHEZ MALDONADO DO A LICENSED
BARBER COSMO FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA OPPOSE SB EIGHT OH
THREE. NICOLE TAYLOR FIRMS
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA LICENSED
COSMETOLOGIST I OPPOSE AS
BEAUTIFULLY. SHALL WE
SACRAMENTO I OPPOSE SB EIGHT OH
THREE. NEVADA A FOR CALIFORNIA-
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AYE
OPPOSED SB EIGHT OH THREE.
HALEY GREEN FAIRFIELD I OPPOSE
SB EIGHT OH THREE. REALLY
COMMUNITIES MONROVIA CALIFORNIA
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB. EIGHT OH
THREE. THE VOLUME COMMUNIS.
KELLY PAYING AYE OPPOSED SB.
EIGHT OH THREE. MY IDEA CAN
YANIS IF YOU ARE NO S. B. A. R.
THREE NO. AMY PASSENGERS
SACRAMENTO I OPPOSE. BURKE
BRANNER FAIRFIELD I OPPOSE.
DANIELLA PLEASE SEE FEDERAL
CALIFORNIA AYE OPPOSED SB.
EIGHT OH THREE. LORENA GONZALEZ
FROM DIXON CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE SB EIGHT OH THREE.
CAITLYN ALLORI YUBA CITY
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE. JANET
SERVING OTHER HYUNDAI CICCO
CALIFORNIA AYE OPPOSED SB EIGHT
OH THREE. CLEAR SNYDER'S
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AYE
OPPOSED SB. EIGHT OH THREE.
TYLER ALLEN FROM YUBA CITY
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE SB. EIGHT
OH THREE. ALEXIS GARCIA FROM
YUBA CITY CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE
SB EIGHT OH THREE. JULIA
EDWARDS ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE. MONIQUE SANDERS
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AYE
OPPOSED. MARINO MARANDA FROM
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA AYE OPPOSED
SB THREE. SHAMANIC MURDOCH
SEGMENT OF CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE.
ANGELICA MURDOCH SACRAMENTO AYE
OPPOSED EIGHT TO SB EIGHT OH
THREE. LARISSA RUIZ I OPPOSE.
MANET RUSSELL SACRAMENTO APPLES.
LEARN ANDERSON SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE. ALEXIS
SALON SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE. CHRISTINE URENA'S
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE. ALEXIS MY K. SACRAMENTO
I OPPOSE. JOHN ABREGO SERRANO
AND I OPPOSE. MY NAME IS KENYA
SILVA AND I OPPOSE SB EIGHT OH
THREE. HELLO WELCOME SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE. NATALIE
WALLACE SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
AYE OPPOSED. BRIANNA LAKE THEM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE.
MEGAN TRAILER CARMICHAEL
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE. CHEN IS
THE BEST COULD STORE BARBER
LICENSE BARBER AND ESTY AND I
OPPOSE SB. EIGHT OH THREE.
JADEN WORKER FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE. JOSLIN
BURGESS I'M FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE. MARIA
VARGAS I OPPOSE. SACRAMENTO
MODESTO AYE OPPOSED. ALL THE
HUNDRED OVER AUTO MODESTO
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE AS PETER
THREE. THERE ARE NONE OF US
COULD STOCKTON CALIFORNIA AND
AYE OPPOSED A SPEED OF THREE.
ROSSIO FLS FOR MERCED
CALIFORNIA AYE OPPOSED SB.
EIGHT OH THREE. MARBLES NEAR
MODESTO CALIFORNIA APPLES.
CHRISTOPER AROUND SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND PULLS. FRED
JONES ON BEHALF OF THE
PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY FEDERATION
OF CALIFORNIA APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS BUT WE'VE GOT A LOT
OF WORK TO DO THANK YOU WE
OPPOSE. NO LOOKS LIKE WE'VE
CONCLUDED ALL THE PUBLIC.
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS IN THE GALLERY
LIKE TO THANK OUR SERGEANTS FOR
HELPING TO FACILITATE THAT
EVERYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO SIGNIFY
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
THANKS AGAIN FOR ALLOWING US
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
FULLY PARTICIPATE IN A
DEMOCRACY THANK YOU AGAIN TO
OUR SERGEANTS WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO REMOTE TESTIMONY. AND JOB
WILL OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN A
REMOTE ROOM THE SERGEANTS CAN
ALSO HELP ASSISTANT OPEN BAR
LINES THEN FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE WHO ARE
ALSO IN THE BUILDING FOR REMOTE
TESTIMONY AND THEN THAT WILL BE
CONCLUDED BY. UP ON THE PHONE
LINE SO WE'LL GO THEN TO REMOTE
TESTIMONY. I NEED TO CROSS
EXAMINE CISCO BUSINESS OWNER
RESTITUTION OPPOSE. CHERYL
SNODGRASS SAN FRANCISCO
BUSINESS OWNER OPPOSED. JEREMY
FEDERICO SACRAMENTO BUSINESS
OWNER STRONG OPPOSITION. I
DON'T KNOW GOES SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND. HOLLY BACK A
VOLCANO CALIFORNIA OPPOSE. HE'S
MADRE METAL SACRAMENTO OPPOSE.
TO THE SACRAMENTO- BROS.
DIMITRI TERRA- SEGMENT I OPPOSE.
I WAS IN A YEAR SACRAMENTO I
OPPOSE. GREG RUPERT SACRAMENTO
I STRONGLY OPPOSE.AMY GARCIA
IN SACRAMENTO NAPA'S.
RISEBOROUGH SACRAMENTO POST. MY
NAME IS BAILEY LANHAM FROM WHAT
I CALIFORNIA AND AYE OPPOSED SB
EIGHT OH THREE. MY NAME IS
EMILY STARKEY I'M SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. MY NAME'S QUINCY FALLS
I'M FROM PLACERVILLE CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE. JOCELYN JONES
ANDERSON AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS ARGHA COMBO FROM
WENDY'S CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER GARCIA
FROM SACRAMENTO AND I BOTH. MY
NAME IS OSCAR VIGNA I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE. MY
NAME IS FREEDOM FROM SACRAMENTO
AND I OPPOSE AS WELL- MY NAME
IS JORGE- I'M FOR SACRAMENTO
AND I OPPOSE. MY NAME IS ROSE
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO AND I
OPPOSE. MY NAME IS MILLION A
CENTER I'M SORRY I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO I OPPOSE. WHEN IT'S
FULLY PREVENT I'M FROM CHICO
AND I OPPOSE. MY NAME'S COLIN
FROM SACKING OPPOSE. MY NAME'S
SELENA GRAHAM FROM SACRAMENTO
AND I OPPOSE. MY NAME'S DURING
CLUB ALLEN I'M FROM WEEKLY
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE. MY
NAME SOUND FROM YOUR CITY AND I
OPPOSE. MY NAME IS HAN REGAL
I'M FROM THE CITY AND I OPPOSE.
MY NAME FUTURE COMMENTS I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE.
MY NAME'S LIZ I'M FORMER PINES
AND I OPPOSE. MY NAMES CAMERON
SACCA AND I'M FROM BACK OF A
AND I OPPOSE. CARCINOID HOME IN
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
PENSION SACRAMENTO AND I
DISAPPROVE. MY NAME'S LEO
CARILLO AND I DISAPPROVE OF SB
EIGHT OH THREE. HI MY NAME'S
HERE ALMOST ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE. MY NAME'S GABRIEL
GARCIA I'M FROM SACRAMENTO AND
I OPPOSE. MY NAME IS JAMIE
BREAKS AND I'M FROM WHEN THE
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE. MY
NAME'S HANNAH WILLIAMS I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE. MY
NAME'S ALYSSA LOPEZ I'M FROM
NAME'S CAMILLE CARS OR ANY I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS JORDAN LYNCH I'M
MONDAY'S IN THE CARPET AND I
OPPOSE. THE CAMERA MY NAME IS
DAVE YOU ARE I OPPOSE OF
EVERYTHING ESPECIALLY SB. EIGHT
OH THREE. SACRAMENTO AND I
OPPOSE. MY NAME IS BERNIE COME
FROM SACRAMENTO AYE OPPOSED SB
EIGHT OH THREE. MY NAME TWENTY
SEVEN FIRMS WHAT LAN AND I
OPPOSE. MY NAME IS BERNADETTE
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO AND I
OPPOSE. MY NAME VOTE PADA I'M
FROM MILAN AND I OPPOSE. HI MY
NAME IS RICK I'M FROM
CALIFORNIA AND AYE OPPOSED SB
EIGHT OF THREE. MY NAME IS
JASON AND VALLEJO AND I OPPOSE.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE CONCLUDED.
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION IN THE REMOTE
HEARING ROOM. THANK YOU AGAIN
TO THE ASSEMBLY STARTED FOR
HELPING TO FACILITATE A SMOOTH
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION WHILE
ALSO RECOGNIZING ARE DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS. WE NOW MOVE ON TO
THE OPERATOR FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
OPERATOR TO IT JUST AS A
REMINDER FOR INDIVIDUALS
CALLING IN THE PHONE LINES
SIMPLY SIGNIFIER OPPOSITION
NAME AND AFFILIATION. AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. I'M SORRY
WE'RE- ONE MOMENT. FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE ALREADY IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE DO NOTHING IF YOU
PRESS THE NUMBERSGET WITH. YOU
FROM THE QUEUE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT ZERO
THREE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE
FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS SAMANTHA MANYONGA FROM
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND AYE
OPPOSED EIGHT- THREE. AND FOR
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS A FEDERAL WOULD HAVE
BEEN THAT AND I'VE BEEN A
REGISTERED COSMETOLOGIST AND I
FEEL FOR STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FOR OVER FORTY YEARS AND I.
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB VS I'M SORRY
NOT SB EIGHT OH THREE THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS. DUROCHER FORTY FROM
SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE ASSOCIATED
BARBARA COLLEGE AND HAD BEEN A
BARBER SCHOOL BRITISH. FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS. HI STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. YOU CANNOT CUT.
FORTY TWO SEVEN PLEASE SHARE OF
THE ENERGY. AND CROP. NINE FOUR
ZERO THREE YOUR MIND IS A
PLEASE CLAP. OKAY. SEVEN MY-
YOUR LIFE IF I HAD. AFTER
THIRTY NINE NINETY BUCKLEY. I
THE- THANK YOU ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE
THOUGHT BUSH EVEN AT ONE POINT.
FIFTY FIFTY YOU'RE NOT OPEN
PLEASE WHERE. NEVER CALLING
BACK BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA AND
OUT OF THE BILL IF I APPROVE IT.
NINE FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WE'VE PERHAPS.
HELLO MY NAME JUDITH ORTEGA
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND
AYE OPPOSED SB THREE. MY FOR
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN I
HAVE. HI MY NAME'S BERNARD AND
I OPPOSE SB EIGHT ZERO THREE.
NINETY SIX TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOT AND
SHALL NOT LIVING UP ON AND I
WAS ABLE TO. NINETY SIX TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS UP IS WHAT.
HOLD IT OPEN. OR FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER
LOPEZ- FROM HAWTHORNE
CALIFORNIA MCCARTY BUDGET
STUDENT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB. EIGHT OH THREE. THE
FOURTEENTH YOUR MIND OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LOLA GROUP. I'M FROM ANAHEIM
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE S. B. EIGHT OH THREE. MY
RECENT. GIVEN THE OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KEREN
VICTORIA MARACA MALEKI KAUFMAN
COLLEGES AYE OPPOSED AT THE
RATE OF THREE. THANK YOU TWENTY
NINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN SHOULD
GO AHEAD AND- THE NEW YORK
CHARMOUTH APPROPRIATE BOND. AND
I UPLOAD SB EIGHT OH THREE.
NINE THREE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS UP PLEASE SLAP. TURN
YOUR CABLE I AM ACROSS. OR YEAH
S. B. IT'LL CREATE. NINE SIX
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YES GO AHEAD THANK YOU MY NAME
IS KAREN STARTED SUPERVISOR
ADVANCE BE DETECTED CALAMY IN
CORONA CALIFORNIA AND AYE
OPPOSED SB EIGHT OH THREE. I
FOUR EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME. ACOSTA I MADE SORRY. YEAH
SB THIRTY. NINE SIX SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS RATE STAYING
BACK BUSINESS OWNER SAN MARCOS
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE S. B. EIGHT OH THREE
THANK YOU. FIVE SIX FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME PARTY MARLENE
ORTEGA. BUSINESS OWNER BURKE
OKAY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AT.
MY. THREE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KERNEWEK LIKE CRAP BUDGET YOUR
AND THE PROGRAM. AT THE END AND
THERE ESCONDIDA X. EIGHTY
THREE. NINETY SIX THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
DANA PATTERSON FROM TRIBUTE GO
CANYON CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB EIGHT OH THREE I'M A
LICENSED COSMETOLOGIST BARBER
AND BUSINESS OWNER. I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU FOR IT
OPERATIVE YOU COULDN'T JUST FOR
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE'VE NOW
REACHED THE TWENTY MINUTE MARK
FOR. THE LIMITS OF PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION BUT
BECAUSE OF TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES WILL ALLOW FOR
ADDITIONAL FIVE MINUTES TO
ADDITIONAL FIVE MINUTES AND-THEN WILL CONCLUDE OUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
TO CONTINUE. YOU MISTER CHAIR.
NINE FOUR FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
SIX FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL PETER.
BUSINESS OWNER CALLED RECALL
JUST STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT
ZERO THREE. I'M THREE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS ERIC PAPADOPOLOUS THE
CALIFORNIA I AM PUTTING
POLITICS TODAY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE BE ABLE TO BRING. NINE
FOUR FORTY EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ARLENE
ALLIANCE OR NO PAUL MITCHELL
THE SCHOOL SACRAMENTO I PULLED.
MY SIX THIRTY FIVE YOU'RE NOT.
BEFORE. MY NAME IS JAPANESE
EVAN LONG WEEKEND THE CURRENT
COSMETOLOGY STUDENT MY OPPOSE
IT SB EIGHTY THREE. NINE SIX
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
MATTHEW KOGAN FROM LOS ANGELES
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT
OH THREE. THANK YOU NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS ERIC GILL COME I'M
FROM ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB ZERO
THREE. I'M SEVENTY ONE. YOUR
MIND OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME'S KATIE SUTHERLAND AND I'M
A STUDENT AT GOLDEN WEST
COLLEGE IN HUNTINGTON BEACH AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT OH
THREE. I'M THREE SEVEN TWO
NINE. NINE OF DISCO HELP. LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND PROFESSIONAL WHO WILL
BOTH WE STRONGLY OPPOSE YOU
KNOW IT'S GREAT. ALL. NINE FOUR
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND. HI. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO JOHN
DOMINGUEZ A STRONGLY OPPOSE S.
B. EIGHT OH THREE. I'M FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS CARLOS MEDINA IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M IN THE CIVIC
STUDENT AT SF ICY I OPPOSE SB
THREE. NINE FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS ASHLEY
WHITEMAN JONES I AM A LICENSED
COSMETOLOGIST IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE SB
EIGHT OH THREE. FIVE SIX OH
EIGHT. ONE OF THE PRINCIPAL HAS.
I DON'T. MY NAME'S LOGINS FROM
HER CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
YOUR- THANKS TWENTY FOUR YOUR
IS OPEN IS GOING. MY NAME TO
GEORGE I. ANDERSON IN BEVERLY
HILLS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE. MY
FORTY SIXTY YOUR LEFT OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. APODIDAE
PUBLIC ALLOW FOR PAUL MITCHELL
SCHOOLS AND I POSE SB EIGHT OH
THREE. NINETY SIX OH SIX YOUR
LIFE IS GOING. MY NAME DARK.
HOW FAR. I THANK AS. EIGHT FOUR
THREE. MY FIVE NINE OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD- MY NAME IS HALL I
WOULD CHECK AND EDUCATE AND I
LIVE AND BARBER WITH MANY HOT.
STUDENTS AND WE LOOK THAT BEING
NO. THREE MY FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
ELEVEN THOUSAND GO AHEAD. SHE'S
SEVEN EIGHT THE NEW THIS BUT-
HI MY NAME IS GREGORY ARE
LOOKING THEN GO AND I OPPOSED
SB. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OP JUST
ONE ADDITIONAL CALLER PLEASE AS
WE'VE NOW REACHED THE TWENTY
FIVE MINUTE MARK. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND NINE THREE
SIXTY ONE YOUR MIND IS A- HI MY
NAME IS ALEXIS GOMEZ AND I'M A
LICENSED COSMETOLOGIST AND
LICENSED BARBER HERE IN SANTA
FE SPRINGS CALIFORNIA I VALUE
EDUCATION AND I OPPOSE AT THE
EIGHT OH THREE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE NOW CONCLUDES THE
PORTION OF THE HEARING IN WHICH
WE HEARING PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. WELL NOW MOVES TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO THE AUTHOR
AND JUST AS A REMINDER THERE IS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FOR
CERTAINLY HAS SPARKED A GREAT
CONVERSATION- HERE TODAY AND
APPRECIATE OF THOSE WHO
TESTIFIED WHETHER IN SUPPORT OR
AGAINST I JUST HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS FROM THE AUTHOR
BECAUSE I RECEIVED AS I'VE BEEN
SITTING HERE RECEIVING TEXTS
FROM INDIVIDUALS MY DISTRICT
ADDISON MIXED AND SO DOES THE
SOME CLARIFICATION AS RELATES
TO- THIS PROPOSAL ONE HOW DID-
WE DO DERIVE FROM. CITY
REDUCING FROM SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS TO ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND THEN DOES THAT DIMINISH ANY
KIND OF WAY WITH RESPECT TO THE
TRAINING BECAUSE OF SIXTEEN
HOURS FOR A STUDENT TO GO
THROUGH TO GET THEIR LICENSE
AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO REDUCE
IT TO ONE THOUSAND HOURS- WHAT
IS THE MECHANISMS TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU KNOW THAT TOP THE SIX
THE SIX HUNDRED HOURS
ABSOLUTELY- CAPTURED AND
TRAINING IS NOT DIMINISHED TO A
QUICK. INDIVIDUAL SPECIAL
AROUND SAFETY. AND AN OTHERWISE
MOVING FORWARD. WELL IN FIRST
PLACE BOTH THE CURRENT LAW AND
THIS BILL. THE STANDARD IS NOT
LESS THAN SO UNDER THE CURRENT
LAW IT'S NOT LESS THAN. SIXTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS UNDER THIS BILL
IT'S NOT LESS THAN ONE THOUSAND
HOURS. THE QUESTION IS WHAT ARE
THE STUDENTS DOING FOR SIXTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS. IN COSMETOLOGY
COSMETOLOGY PROGRAM OR FIFTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS INTO BARBERING
PROGRAM. V. THIS LEGISLATOR
LEGISLATURE AND THE COMMITTEES
BOTH IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE HAVE BEEN ASKING THAT
QUESTION FOR YEARS. AND WE HAVE
ASKED THE INDUSTRY TO
PARTICIPATE WITH US IN THE
SCHOOLS THAT ARE INVOLVED. IN
ASSESSING THE PROGRAMS AND THE
CURRICULUM REQUIREMENTS AND THE
REASON AND THE RATIONALE FOR
SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS FOR
COSMETOLOGIST. WITHOUT RESULT.
AND IN FACT THE RESPONSE THAT
WE HAVE RECEIVED. EACH AND
EVERY TIME WAS SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS IN THE CASE OF
COSMETOLOGISTS FIFTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS FOR BARBERS. IS
APPROPRIATE. AS WE IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE WATCHED THESE
PARTS OF THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY RHODE ISLAND VERMONT
NEW YORK TEXAS TEXAS. STEADILY
REDUCING THE NOT LESS THAN
HOURLY REQUIREMENT. AS I
MENTIONED VERMONT TEXAS A
THOUSAND HOURS RHODE ISLAND SIX
HUNDRED HOURS NEW YORK ABOUT A
THOUSAND OR SO CERTAINLY LISTEN
SIXTEEN HUNDRED HOURS AND WE
STAY THE SAME. SO THIS TIME WE
ASK AGAIN. NO RESPONSE FROM
INDUSTRY AS YOU'VE HEARD EXCEPT-
COMPLAINTS AND REQUESTED A
REMAIN THE STATUS QUO IN THE
BOARD WORKED WITH US THIS TIME
TO IN FACT DETERMINE THAT A
THOUSAND HOURS APPEARED
APPROPRIATE WITH AN INCREASE BY
THE WAY IN THE MANNER TRAINING.
SPECIFIED FOR DISINFECTION AND
SANITATION BECAUSE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE COSMETOLOGY
TRAINING CURRICULUM AND YOU
LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF HOURS
THAT ARE REQUIRED FOR ITS
SANITATION AND DISINFECTING.
AND I FORGET WHETHER WAS TWENTY
OR SIXTY OR MAYBE A HUNDRED I'D
HAVE TO LOOK. I DON'T THINK IT
WAS THAT MUCH FOR THAT
PARTICULAR A SEGMENT OF HEALTH
AND SAFETY YOU WOULD BE
SURPRISED AND YOU WOULD SAY IF
YOU'RE SPENDING SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOURS IN A CURRICULUM. AND THIS
IS AN INDUSTRY WERE INTERESTED
IN CONSUMER PROTECTION WHY
WOULDN'T YOU SPEND MORE TIME.
WORKING ON. DISINFECTION AND
SANITATION AND SO. IT APPEARED
TO AT LEAST SOME OF US THAT A
THOUSAND HOURS. WHAT'S UP WAS
APPROPRIATE CERTAINLY CERTAINLY
APPROPRIATE VERMONT TEXAS NEW
YORK. WE ASK THE BOARD THE
BOARD- AGREED WITH US. SUBJECT
TO THE LIMIT THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'VE TAKEN IN THIS BILL.
SO WE DON'T THINK. WE ME DON'T
THINK THAT THIS IS GOING TO
IMPACT HEALTH AND SAFETY
CONSUMER PROTECTION OR FRANKLY
THE TRAINING OF THE STUDENTS IN
THE SCHOOLS AND I THINK YOU ALL
ARE WELL AWARE THAT STUDENTS
PAY A FAIR AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR
THE SCHOOLS THAT CAN BE UPWARDS
OF FIFTEEN THOUSAND TWELVE TO
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
TRAINING PROGRAM SO WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE HOURS
REQUIRED. WE SAID IT RIGHT.
BECAUSE IT CAN BE A BARRIER TO
EMPLOYMENT. IF THE COSTS ARE
HIGH THE HOURS ARE EXCESSIVE
AND THAT'S WHAT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THAT WE WERE TRYING TO
DO HERE AND IF WE HAVEN'T FOR
NOT GETTING IT RIGHT. WE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE
TO GET IT RIGHT WE OWE IT TO
THE STUDENTS WHO ARE INTERESTED
IN CAREERS IN BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY. AND ALL OF THE
OTHER FEELS REGULATED BY THIS
PARTICULAR BOARD. CENTER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE YOUR
RESPONSE. I HAVE OTHERS ONE
ADDITIONAL QUESTION- BECAUSE
WHEN I GO GET MY HAIR CUT. THAT
WAS A JOKE. OF THE REAL
QUESTION IS WITH THE REDUCTION
IN HOURS- AFFECTS STUDENTS-
THAT MOVED OUT OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MOVED INTO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA NO SHOULD NOT
AFFECT THEM AT THAT HAS TO DO
WITH THE TESTING REQUIREMENTS
IN THIS THAT THE OTHER AND WILL
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS. THAT
THERE IS ABILITY AND MOBILITY
WITH RESPECT TO BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY BUT IT'S NOT MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE WILL
BE ANY ANY ANY ADVERSE IMPACT
THANK AND IF IT TURNS OUT THAT
THERE IS WILL FIX THAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. I SEE NO
DIGITAL- QUESTIONS COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME I JUST WANT TO AGAIN
REMIND INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD-
WE'VE BEEN ON THE PHONES THAT
THEY CAN ALSO SUBMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE BY
EMAIL OR THROUGH THE ONLINE
PORTAL FOR ME TO GET MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO DO NOT GET TO
TESTIFY. DUE TO TIME
CONSTRAINTS FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE
BY EMAIL. OR THROUGH THE PORTAL.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS HAVE BEEN MEMBERS AT
THIS TIME SEE NON. KEVIN ROTH
TO WISH TO CLOSE THANK YOU
CHAIR LET ME JUST MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS TO ADDRESS THOSE WHO
SPOKE BOTH HERE AND OUTSIDE.
OUTSIDE THE CHAMBER I WANT TO
ASSURE THEM THAT- THOSE THAT
ARE EVER INVOLVED WITH THE
OPPOSITION THAT BIG
CORPORATIONS HAVE NOT BEEN
INVOLVED IN DRAFTING. THE
PROVISIONS CONTAINED IN THE
SUNSET BILL. A RATHER WAS A
VERY DEDICATED TEAM OF STAFFERS
BOTH HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE.
WHO WORKED ON IT THIS YEAR AND
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THESE
ISSUES. FRANKLY FOR YEARS. N.
AS TO THOSE WHO SAY THAT.
QUESTION WHETHER YOU KNOW
REGULATION. CAN SERVE AS A
BARRIER TO EMPLOYMENT I THINK
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR IN THEIR
NUMEROUS STUDIES THAT.
GOVERNMENT REGULATION OF
BUSINESS AND OCCUPATIONS CAN
SERVE AS A BARRIER TO
EMPLOYMENT BOTH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE NATION.
AND WE REGULATE TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS. RECEIVE THE TRAINING
THEY NEED AND DESERVE. WITHOUT
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS SUCH AS
EXCESSIVE TRAINING REQUIREMENTS
OR IN SOME CASES EXCESSIVE.
TUITION NO MORE. AND NO LESS
AND AS I MENTIONED TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN MY RESPONSE.
YOU KNOW I I'M DELIGHTED THAT
WE HAVE INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVES PARTICIPATING
IN THIS DISCUSSION TODAY.
FRANKLY THESE COMMITTEES HAVE
BEEN REQUESTING THE INDUSTRY
AND THOSE INVOLVED WITH IT
INCLUDING THE SCHOOLS. TO WORK
WITH US TO REVIEW THE SPECIFIC
TRAINING HOURS REQUIRED. IN
LIGHT OF ADVANCING TECHNOLOGY.
BUT WITHOUT RESULT AS I
INDICATED OTHER THAN. THE
RESPONSE OF THE STATUS QUO IS
OKAY SO WITH THE BOARD'S HELP
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT
EFFORT THIS YEAR. TO PROVIDE
THE ANALYSIS AND OF COURSE YOU
SEE THE RESULT NOW I WANT TO
STATE ON THE RECORD THAT I WILL
COMMIT TO WORK WITH THOSE
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THOSE
WHO SPOKEN TODAY. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS BILL TO TRY
TO DO THE WORK THAT WE HAVE
BEEN REQUESTING FRANKLY FOR
YEARS. AND WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIR I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH JIM ROTH- OF HERSELF IT TO
LIGHT I WOULD LIKE TO. COMMEND
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS ISSUE- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WELL NO THAT YOU'VE
SERVED AS CHAIR OF THE SENATE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE
JUST STARTING THIS YEAR. AND
WHICH YOU'VE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT ISSUES
TO BE IRONED OUT- PRIOR TO YOU
TAKING ON THE PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING AS CHAIR. AND YET. AS
WE HAVE TRIED TO TACKLE SIXTEEN
PLUS BOARD TO BE ROSE. I'VE
DONE SO AND HAD BEEN AND
CONTINUES CONVERSATION TO
ENSURE THAT ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
VIEWPOINTS ARE WELL HEARD AND
ACKNOWLEDGED- SO WITH THAT
SAID- DR- MOTION AND A SECOND.
BY SOMEONE OVER CHEN THANK YOU
BYE SIMILAR GIPSON COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB EIGHT ZERO THREE ROTH D.
PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORA. BERMAN BERMAN HI
BLOOM. BLOOM HI CHEN CHEN HI
CHIU. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
DELI DELI HI FONG. FONG
UPLOADING GIPSON. GIPSON HI
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN IRWIN HI
MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA HI
MULLIN MULLIN I SALAS SALAS HI
TEAM. WEBER WEBER HI. FORTY
NINE ZERO KNOWS FOURTEEN EYES
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
THANK MEMBERS WHO HAVE JOINED
US HERE IN THE CHAMBERS FOR
COMING IN PERSON TO SIGNIFY
YOUR POSITION ON THE SENATE
BILL. EIGHT ZERO THREE. SENATOR
ROTH WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
FINAL ITEM THIS IS SENATE BILL.
EIGHT ZERO SIX FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX. HE'S PREFERRED
PRESERVATIVE READY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS THE SUNSET
BILL FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA HEALING ARTS THE
CHANGES IN THIS BILL STEM FROM
A SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT
PROCESS INCLUDING TWO RECENT
PUBLIC HEARINGS AS THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS IN THE ASSEMBLY
PROFESSIONS HELLO THIS YEAR O
DISCUSS THIS IMPORTANT
REGULATORY BODY IN THE VERY IS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH IT. I WITHOUT
THIS BILL TODAY THIS MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA WILL EXPIRE
THE BILL EXTENDS THE BOARD'S
OPERATIONS FOR TWO YEARS THE
MEDICAL BOARD'S ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS STARTING WITH HAVE
COMPLAINTS FROM THE PUBLIC ARE
HANDLED STRETCHING ALL THE WAY
TO THE END OF THE BOARD AND ITS
MEMBERS MAKES DECISIONS ABOUT
LICENSEE DISCIPLINE HAS BEEN
THE SUBJECT OF SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN. AND QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS AND THE PUBLIC ALIKE
INCLUDING A RECENT LOS ANGELES
TIMES NEWSPAPER ARTICLE TODAY
SIGNIFICANTLY SB EIGHT OH SIX
PROPOSES ENFORCEMENT MONITOR AT
THE MEDICAL BOARD TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE INDEPENDENT
INFORMATION AND REPORTS ABOUT
WHAT IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING AT
THE MEDICAL BOARD. WITH REGARD
TO A VARIETY OF ISSUES
INCLUDING THE DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS INFORMATION THAT I HOPE
WILL PROVIDE GUIDANCE ON THE
NECESSARY NEXT STEPS TO SUPPORT
THE MEDICAL BOARD'S IMPORTANT
WORK. THE MEASURE ALSO
REINSTATES THE MEDICAL BOARD'S
AUTHORITY I SAY AUTHORITY TO
RECOVER COSTS ACCRUED DURING
ENFORCEMENT CASES. THIS CHANGE
HAS BEEN REQUESTED BY THE
MEDICAL BOARD ITSELF FOR
MULTIPLE SUNSET REVIEWS OVER A
PERIOD OF YEARS. AND IS LIKELY
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL REVENUE
TO OFFSET COSTLY BUT NECESSARY
DISCIPLINARY ACTION. MEMBERS I
KNOW YOU KNOW THIS BUT THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA IS
INSOLVENT AND HAS NOT HAD AN
ADJUSTMENT TO INCREASE
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT BART
OPERATIONS FOR ALMOST FIFTEEN
YEARS. THE BILL INCREASES FEES
FOR ALL MEDICAL BOARD LICENSEES
AND REGISTRANTS AND INCLUDES
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE PROPER
LEGISLATIVE REVIEW OF THIS
PROGRAMS FUNDED CONDITION IN
THE COMING YEAR AND THE NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL FEES. ALL IN
ANTICIPATION OF A FURTHER AND
MORE DETAILED FINANCIAL
ANALYSIS PREPARED BY THE BOARD
ITSELF. ANALYZING EXPENSES AND
REVENUE MANAGEMENT OPERATIONS
AND IMPROVEMENTS THAT COULD BE
ACHIEVED. SENATE BILL EIGHT OH
SIX TAKES THE FIRST STEP IN
RESOLVING ISSUES THAT POSITION
GROUPS AND HEALTH CARE PRESENT
FACILITIES HAVE IDENTIFIED
ABOUT REQUIREMENTS FOR
LICENSURE. DURING PHYSICIAN
PARTICIPATION IN POST GRADUATE
TRAINING CORPS PROGRAMS A VERY
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. THE LAW
ESTABLISHED THROUGH PRIOR
SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD AT THE BOARD'S
REQUEST AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S APPROVAL NOW
REQUIRES A PHYSICIAN TO
COMPLETE THIRTY SIX MONTHS. OR
RECEIVE CREDIT FOR THIRTY SIX
MONTHS OF POST GRADUATE
TRAINING. THREE YEARS IS THE
SHORTEST RESIDENCY PROGRAM AND
MANY PHYSICIANS COMPLETE MANY
MORE THAN THIRTY SIX MONTHS. AS
AMENDED. SB EIGHT OH SIX NOW
INCLUDES PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO TAKE
SHAPE OVER THE NEXT. TWO MONTHS
OR SO TO AUTHORIZE A POSITION
TO BECOME LICENSED AS A FULL
SCOPE PHYSICIAN AND SURGEON
AFTER THE PHYSICIAN AND SURGEON
COMPLETES TWELVE MONTHS OF A
RESIDENCY PROGRAM EXACTLY AS IT
WAS BEFORE THE LAW CHANGE WAS
ADOPTED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. THE POSITION A
SURGEON WOULD THEN HOLD THAT
LICENSE AND ONLY BE ELIGIBLE TO
RETAIN AND RENEW IT UPON
RECEIVING THIRTY SIX MONTHS
CREDIT. FOR POST GRADUATE
TRAINING. FAMILY OR MEDICAL
LEAVE OR OTHER NECESSARILY WILL
STILL BE ACCOMMODATED. FOR
RESIDENT PHYSICIANS AND POST
GRADUATE TRAINING RECEIVE FOR
THE LEAVE PERIOD JUST AS THE
BILL CURRENTLY PROVIDES OUR
GOAL IS TO SEND A BILL TO THE
GOVERNOR THE PROVIDES THE
MEDICAL BOARD WITH THE TOOLS
AND DIRECTION TO ENSURE SWIFT
OUTCOME FOR CASES. MOST
ESPECIALLY CASES INVOLVING
ALLEGATIONS OF SIGNIFICANT
DEVIATION FROM THE STANDARD OF
CARE THAT RESULTED IN PATIENT
HARM. THIS LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
IS JUST THAT A PROCESS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU WOULD
SURE LOVE WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD WITH PATIENCE AND WITH
PHYSICIANS. TO MAKE MEANINGFUL
CHANGES WERE NECESSARY AND TO
GET THIS RIGHT. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SURE ROTH. WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WILL LIMIT THE
TESTIMONY TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. PER INDIVIDUAL FOR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE AARON BROWN ON THE
LINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BILL
PACIFICA I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA HAS INDICATED IN
THE ANALYSIS THE BOARD HAS
ADOPTED A SUPPORT YES AMENDED
POSITION ON SB EIGHT OH SIX.
FIRST THE BOARD IS GRATEFUL
THAT SB EIGHT OH SIX RESTORES
THE BOARD'S AUTHORITY TO OBTAIN
RECOVERY OF ITS INVESTIGATION
AND PROSECUTION COSTS RELATED
TO DISCIPLINARY PROCEEDINGS
AGAINST ITS POSITION LICENSEES
THIS WHITE WOODS PUTS US ON A
PAR WITH OTHER TCA BOARDS. AND
IS EXPECTED TO HELP SUPPORT THE
TIMELY RESOLUTION OF THE
BOARD'S DISCIPLINARY
PROCEEDINGS AND MEDICATE
CERTAIN ENFORCEMENT EXPENSES
FURTHER THE BOARD SUPPORTS
CREATING AN ENFORCEMENT MONITOR
AND HOPE THAT THIS WILL ADD
GREATER TRANSPARENCY TO THE
PROCESS. AND THAT THERE ARE
REPORTS WILL HELP TO SPUR-
ENHANCEMENTS TO THE BOARD'S
AUTHORITY AND RESOURCES THAT
FURTHER ITS CONSUMER PROTECTION
MISSION. THE BOARD WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO ESTABLISH THE
AMOUNT THAT WILL ADEQUATELY
SUPPORT THE BOARD'S OPERATIONS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING WITH THAT WORK IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. FINALLY THE
BOARD REMAINS COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE POSITION COMMUNITY WITH
REGARD TO POST GRADUATE
TRAINING AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATOR AND
STAFF AND STAKEHOLDERS TO IRON
OUT ALL DIFFICULTIES OR STAFFER
HERE I MYSELF. TO AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER. ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT PRIMARY WITNESS. I
HAVE NO OTHER LISTING. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOW MOVE ON TO
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
WITH MEMBERS HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING THE CHAMBERS
WHICH CAN TO SIGNIFY THEIR
SUPPORT. ENCINO MEMBERS IN THE
REMOTE HEARING ROOMS WHICHDEFY
WISHING TO SIGNIFY THEIR
SUPPORT. WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS WISHING TO
SIGNIFY THEIR OPPOSITION HERE
IN THE CHAMBERS WILL GOING. TO
FOR LIMITED TESTIMONY TO NO
MORE THAN TWO MINUTES FOR
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE COMMON VULGAR AND
DINNER SWEATERS WERE MAYOR.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT-
CARMEN OKAY. ALL OF THE TRUMP
AND IF OF THE COMMITTEE DOESN'T
CARE THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS CARMEN VOLVO AND THE
SECOND DIRECTOR CONSUMER
WATCHDOG AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THAT ZERO SIX. UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF
THE MANY MANY CALIFORNIANS TO
THE COMPUTER BACKING. FOR
REFORM OF THE HEADLINE OF
TODAY'S ONLY KIND IN THAT
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE IT ALL
BOTCHED SURGERIES AND THAT. HOW
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD
KEEP NEGLIGENT DOCTORS D.
BUSINESS. AND A PUBLIC MEMBER
OF THE BOARD CAN BEFORE YOU ON
MARCH IN TESTIFIED TO THE SAME
THING YOU SAME QUOTE. FOR W. IS
WE PROTECT THE. DOCTORS WE WORK
PATIENTS ACROSS THE- AND MAY.
OR HAVING ONE BY MY NEGLIGENCE
AND NOT ONE OF THOSE FAMILIES
THAT HEARD OR VALUED OR PROTECT
BY THE MOTHER BOARD THAT IS
CHARGED- I WON'T REPEAT. WHAT
NEED TO WORK. BECAUSE THEY'RE
IN OUR IN MANY OTHER PLACE. BUT
THEY MAKE ONE THING VERY CLEAR
FOR HAVE A DOCTOR BY. AND THE-
STEP. IS TO CHANGE THE BILL OF
POWER IN THE MEDICAL BOARD BY.
PUBLIC MEMBER YOUR FELT. HE-
URGENT. TO AMEND AT THEROCK TO
MAKE THAT- SECONDLY THE LATEST
AMENDMENT. THAT WOULD THE BOARD
ON PRESS. NEW RECORD TISSUE
COMP. AT IN PLACE OF REALLY
POOR ACT IS INCREDIBLY- THE
CALM. LETTER OF ADVICE MARK. BE
COLD. A GET OUT OF FREE HAVE
YOUR BACK. WHAT ARE. IT WAS
ALLOW COMPLAIN BECAUSE- WITH A
SECRET FOR AND VIOLATE. FROM
FEELING THE A CHART TO CALL TO
THE TOP OF THE PAGE. AND COULD
NOT IT REALLY LEAVES OPEN THE-
WHERE NOT ONLY ARE YOU NOT
IMPROVING. OVERSIGHT BY THE
BOARD BUT WITH THIS BILL BUT
THIS AMENDMENT ACTUALLY. MAKES
IT WORK. THE ONLY OTHER PATH
JUSTICE THE BE FAMILIES HAVE A
BELIEVER THEM. BUT TELL CAP ON.
FOR ANOTHER MEDICAL THAT DON'T.
HAVEN'T BEEN AND BY SEVEN FIVE
AND BLOCK YOUR- FROM GETTING A
JOB IN CALL. SO WHEN THE
MEDICAL BOARD ALSO. TO BAD. WE
HAVE AN HOUSE CARE AND WE
SYSTEM BACK AGAIN.
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR. SO WE URGE
TO READ THE CELL INTERESTED. OF
THE MATTER ID AND AMEND AND SIX
TO GET MY COMMITTEE VOTE. AND
REJECT NEW. AT GREATER TO THE
BOARD ALREADY. OUT OPIATE
OVERSEE OF THE- THANK YOU.
THANK NEXT WINNER IN OTHER
LIMON TO TWO PLEASE. THANK YOU
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
DENNIS MERYL THE CALIFORNIANS
THAT SO. WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND STAFF THAT WILL
DISTINCT ON THIS BILL- THE
REASON. DUE TO RECOMMENDED YEAH
MAY REMAIN OPPOSED IMMERSION. I
IT RELATES TO COST CMA IS
CONCERNED WITH REST FOR VERY
THE- FIRST FEMALE CONCERN WITH
THE MEDIC BOARD IS ALREADY HAS
ONE OF THE MORE EXPENSIVE
INVESTIGATING THESE AND SOME OF
THE LAW AND THAT. HI MY THAT
THESE. YOU CAN CONSTRUCT IS
AGAINST LIFE FEES ARE
POTENTIALLY ON LICENSEE TO
PROCESS RIGHT ADDITIONALLY THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO CONTROL THE
BEST COSTS A BEING ABLE CHARGE
AS MUCH AS DEFINED NECESSARY
COMPLETE ADVANCE. SOME CONTROL
COSTS THOUGHT LEADS TO A- THE
MOST CONTROL FOR LIFE THE-
LASTLY THE MEDICAL OF STATE
THAT RESTORING CALM ARE COVERED.
WELL WITH THE TWENTY. THE BOARD
MULTI DOLLARS. ABOUT REQUIRED
TO HOLD OVER BE OF THE POOR
PROCESS TO RECTIFY THAT MATTER.
AS IT RELATES TO THE
POSTGRADUATE TRY LIFE CMA
COALITION WITH THE CAL CRIME
CARE SO. CAL ACADEMY OF FAMILY.
THE MY COULD CAL CHAP. AND THE
FACT. POSITION ONLINE HEALTH
REMAIN EXTREME CONCERNED ABOUT
THEM. OF THE P. WE APPRECIATE
THE FRAMEWORK AND EVERYBODY'S
OUT MINE AS A PPL AGREED
RESULTED IN REDUCED ACCESS TO
MEDICAL PROVIDING POSITION.
LOWERED NUMBER OF SUBJECTS
PSYCHIATRIC EMERGENCY. AND
CREATES PROBLEMS WITH YOUNG
POSITION. FINISHING THEIR
RESIDENCIES AND GOING TO
PRACTICE BECAUSE OF HIGH WINDS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PPL. AMONG
OTHER BARRIERS THAT KEPT. A
COALITION IS OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
THE SOLUTION SHERMAN ROCKETS
PROVIDED A LOOK FORWARD TO
COLLABORATING AND REACHING A
COMPROMISE ON LANGUAGE IT WOULD
SOLVE THE BARRIERS CREATED BY.
THE PPL. FINALLY CMA IS OF IN
CAR ON THE IMPLEMENT OF THE
IMPORT MONITOR BOOK. HOWEVER WE
THAT WILL BE A MAN LANGUAGE
REQUIRED MORE CLEAR. REGARDING
THE OF THE WORK. AND FIX STATE
THAT THE MONITOR BUT THE
UNBIASED EXPERIENCE IN OFFICE
AND ASKED WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH DOCTOR OVER SUMMER
RECESS. TO ADDRESS THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
THE OPPOSITION SENIOR MEMBERS
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS. WHERE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
THIS SPEAKING OPPOSITION.
ENCINO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
A REMOTE TESTIMONY ROOM WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. WISHING TO SIMPLY
SIGNIFIED THEIR NAME AND THEIR
POSITION IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. WE MAY HAVE A MIXED
THANK YOU AT THIS POINT- WE
DIDN'T OPEN IT OR T. YES WILL
INVADE YOUR- OPERATOR WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME AND
THEN WE'LL GO BACK. AS WE-
PASSED THE PORTION OF THEM. I
HEARING FOR PUT TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT SO AT THIS TIME. IF YOU
COULD KIND OF OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLICATION
TO SIGNIFY THEIR OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT OH SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. NINE FIVE EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE FORTY NINE
AHEAD. NINE THREE FOUR FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SHE SURE NUMBERS
TONIGHT AND REPRESENTS THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS SOLUTIONS WE'RE POSE
LESSEN MEDITATION RELATED TO
THE P. P. L. NG THANK YOU. ONE
THREE EIGHTY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
ERIC ANDERSON THE PATIENT
SAFETY LEAGUE IN OPPOSITION
UNLESS AMENDED FIRST OF ALL THE
MEDICAL BOARD SHOULD EXPIRE
DON'T THINK THAT'S A BAD THING
THEIR WEAPON ENFORCEMENT
MONITOR BEFORE AND YET THE
BOARD IS STILL THERE ARE LIKE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAX
NEXT PERSON AS A NOTE. BY THREE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND ASKING ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS THE PROPOSED
MUST MANY DIVISIONS ON THE
RELATED TO POSTGRADUATE
TRAINING LIFE. THANK YOU. MY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PART I THINK
I MIGHT IS ALINA LINE AND I IN
THE CANAL TO MY THREE. I HE.
UNLESS I NEED TO INCLUDE IN IN
THE LIKE WE LOOK LIKE THAT
THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN OH EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
HELLO- COMMITTEE AND NOW WAS
DOWN THAT HELLO IN A- MINUTE
THIS INFORMATION RELATED YEAH
THANK VERY MUCH. ONE SIX EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
HI I'M SUSAN LAWRENCE SURVIVE
OF THE DISABLING ASSAULT I'M IN
STRONG OPPOSITION AND I URGE
YOU TO WITHHOLD YOUR VOTE TODAY
WE MUST DO BETTER TO DEAL WITH
AND PREVENT. NEFARIOUS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC HARM IN CALIFORNIA
I'VE BEEN HUSBAND FOR TEN YEARS
DUE TO THE STATE NEEDS TO STOP
THANK YOU. NINE THREE NINETY.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS RANDALL
ACRE PARK THE PSYCHIATRIC
CONDITIONS ALLIANCE CALIFORNIA.
ARE FIFTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE PTO THANK YOU.
MY NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M TREATING YOU FOR PRESIDENT
OF CALIFORNIA FAMILY PRACTICE
IN THAT LIGHT. A CONSUMER AND
ALSO CONSUMER OF LICENSED
MIDWIFERY CARE. EXAM OF THE
CONSUMER ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
THAT HAS OVER FIVE THOUSAND
SUPPORTERS. AND WE FOCUS ON
INCREASING THE GROCERY ACCESS
AND GROWTH OPTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. WE OPPOSE
SB EIGHT OH SIX. I'M NOT
COMMENDED TO INCLUDE AN
INDEPENDENT LICENSED MIDWIFE
BOARD. NINE FIVE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS THIRTY AS I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND
I RECEIVEDWELL WOMAN CARE FROM
A LICENSED MIDWIFE. SB EIGHT OH
SIX UNLESS AMENDED TO INCLUDE A
LIKE AND WEBER EIGHT POINT. MY
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ANNETTE RAMIREZ FROM MANHATTAN
BEACH CALIFORNIA I'M A PATIENT
SAFETY ADVOCATE THE CONSUMER
WATCHDOG MY LIFE IS GREATLY
HARMED BY MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE IN
TWENTY TWELVE AND I AM NOW
LIVING IN THE QUALITY AND HE IN
A WHEELCHAIR. TO THIS END I
WOULD GIVEN NO SUPPORTER
COMMUNICATION FROM CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL CARE VERY MUCH I
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL AT THE END
OF THE- THANK YOU. NINE ONE OH
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
CHEN CAMEL FOUNDER AND CEO OF
THE BACKPACKS BASED OUT OF
CLAREMONT INTO TINY WITH THE
CLIENT I REPRESENT THOUSANDS OF
WORKING FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WHEN I EXPRESS OUR
COLLECTIVE OPPOSITION FOR S. B.
YOU KNOW SEX UNLESS AMENDED TO
SUPPORT A LICENSED MIDWIFE
BOARD WHICH WILL RESOLVE THE
CURRENT REGULATORY FAMILY.
EVERYBODY AROUND THE BACK THANK
YOU. ONE SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DENISE JOHNSON I LIVE IN TRACY
CALIFORNIA I AM AN ADVOCATE FOR
THE WATCHDOG ORGANIZATION AND-
I OPPOSED THE BILL SB EIGHT OH
SIX. THE RECOMMENDED TO INCLUDE
A PUBLIC BOARD MEMBER MAJORITY
THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MONEY TIME
I AM FROM KERN COUNTY AYE
OPPOSED THE BILL SB EIGHT OR
SIX O'CLOCK I THINK YOU CREATE
A PUBLIC BOARD MEMBER MAJORITY
THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM MICHELLE MONTARA
ROBINSON FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE SB
EIGHTY SIX UNLESS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE A PUBLIC MEMBER
MAJORITY THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M JUST BEING BACK
AT FROM KERN COUNTY I'M A
LICENSED MIDWIFE AND I AM IN
OPPOSITION. SB EIGHT OH SIX
ANOTHER COMMENDED TO INCLUDE
LANGUAGE FOR MY WIFE TO HAVE
THEIR OWN BOARD THANK YOU. MY
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS TAMMY MAKE MACULA
CALIFORNIA I'M A PATIENT SAFETY
ADVOCATE CONSUMER WATCHDOG
BOARD MEMBER AND MOTHER OF ALEX
WHO WAS KILLED BY A NEGLIGENT
DR I OPPOSE SB ANALYTICS UNLESS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE A PUBLIC
MEMBER MAJORITY THANK YOU. NINE
THREE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS STRUCTURE AND I OPPOSE
SB SIX MONTHS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE A LICENSED MIDWIFE
BOARD. NINE THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS MARIAN
HOLLINGSWORTH AND I'M A
SUFFICIENT SAFETY ADVOCATES OF
IN CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE SB EIGHT
OH SIX UNLESS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE A PUBLIC MEMBER
MAJORITY THANK YOU. MY TO SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS MARK WILSON I LIVE
IN NEW PER BEACH CALIFORNIA I
AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL
EIGHT OH SIX UNLESS IT INCLUDES
OF PUBLIC BOARD MEMBER MAJORITY
THE ONLY WAY THAT PROTECT.
PATIENTS LIKE MY MOM WHO IS
KILLED THIS PAST YEAR GOOD
MAKING MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE.
THANK YOU. MY FORCE THIRTY
FIVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLY MAN AND SENATOR ROSS.
I AM FROM BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA MY NAME IS TRACY
DEMEANOR I STRONGLY OPPOSE. SB
EIGHT OH SIX AND LEFT A
MAJORITY BOARD MEMBER. IT'S
ADDED BACK TO THE BILL AND I AM
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CONFIDENTIAL LETTER WHEN IT
COMES TO LIFE AND DEATH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MY NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN NINETY ONE YOU MAY BE
A NEW ATHLETIC. APOLOGIES MY
NAME IS THE OKAY AREA AND I'M
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AYE OPPOSED
SB ASX UNLESS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE A PUBLIC BOARD MEMBER
MAJORITY THANK YOU. ONE SIX
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
DANIEL CHAVEZ MIDWIFE AND I
OPPOSE S. B. IF YOU DON'T FIX
UNLESS AMENDED TO INCLUDE A
LIFE AND MIDWIFE COURT THANK
YOU. NINE SEVEN OH ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN
OKAY HI MY NAME IS WILLIAM
ARTHUR RURAL AND I AM A
LICENSED MIDWIFE AFTER
EXPERIENCING MEDICAL
NEGLIGENCE- IN THE HOSPITAL
WITH MY FIRST SON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT
AFFECTS UNLESS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE ELECTRIC MIDWIFERY
BOARD. NINE ONE FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DRAGANA DAVIS
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LICENSE NUMBER
ONE. THANK YOU FOR THE REFUND
OF DEATH IT AFFECTS THE LATEST
ON DISCIPLINARY CASES ALTHOUGH
HELPFUL ONLY SCRATCH THE
SURFACE. OF THE HISTORICALLY
SPEAKING THE MANAGEMENT OF A
LOT OF PROGRAMS UNDER THE
MEDICAL BOARD THEREFORE. FROM
THE QUOTE I'M NOT THE MAN THAT-
THE FORMATION OF A LIFE MIDWIFE
FOR THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN TEN
YOUR IS OPEN I HAD. BATTLING.
YEAH HOW PROVIDERS SACRAMENTO
HEALTH. YOU. THANKS A LOT IT
PROVIDES FORMATION OF THE LIGHT
RIGHT. FOR MY THREE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THIS GUY HAS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
MAKING THREE SOMETHING OF OUR
HEALTH PLUS AT RESPECTFULLY
WITH OPPOSING AMENDED.
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO THE
GRADUATE TRAINING FOR IN THE
QUARTER CONTINUING OUR WORK ON
THAT THANK. WE HAVE NO FOR
COMMENT AND CAN'T. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATIVE WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE PORTION OF THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. WELL THEN OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHICH IS BEGIN SUPPORT
AS A PASS THAT OVER THE INITIAL
TIME SO OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. SIMPLY
WISHING TO SIGNIFY THEIR
SUPPORT BY SAYING THEIR NAME
AND POSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK UP IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT ZERO
SIX. YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MY FOUR OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR A
MOMENT BACK REPRESENTING THE
OSTEOPATHIC PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS OF CALIFORNIA. IT IS A
QUICKLY COMPONENT THAT EXTEND
OUT THE PRODUCT MEDICAL BOARD.
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK FROM
BOTH COMMITTEES. ESPECIALLY AS
IT RELATES TO THE CONTINUING
MEDICAL EDUCATION THANKS TO GET.
MY ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PODIA ETTRICK
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
SPECIFICALLY OF PROVISIONS
PERTAINING TO THE COULD YOU ASK
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
MOST NOTABLY THE UPDATE TO THE
PROBATION OF SCOTIA
REQUIREMENTS THANK YOU TO SEND
ROCKETS A MEMBER THOUGH FOR
YOUR WORK. ONE MOMENT FAR NEXT
MY NUMBER. MY TWO FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN RECOGNIZE
REPRESENTING THE CENTER FOR
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW AND THE
PROPORTIONS OF AVIATOR SIX
SPECIFICALLY TO RECENT
AMENDMENTS REGARDING IN THE
ENFORCEMENT MONITOR AND
ALLOWING THE LEGISLATURE TO
REVISIT THE FEE PROVISIONS NEXT
YEAR WE DO URGE YOU TO
RECONSIDER THE PROVISIONS
RELATED TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE
LADDER. AND ALLOWING A
PHYSICIAN TO SURRENDER THE
LICENSE FOR TEN YEARS WITHOUT A
FACE HERE APPLICATION
ADDITIONALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS ON A
PUBLIC MEMBER MAJORITY OF THE
COURT. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN Q. CASING
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING THE CHAMBERS TO
SIGNIFY THEIR SUPPORT AND NOW
CONCLUDING THE TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR MEMBERS TO SIGNIFY
THE SUPPORT WILL BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
BEGIN WITH DR WEBBER. THANK YOU
CHAIR. FIRST I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE AUTHOR- SENATOR
ROTH AS CHAIR OF THE SENATE AND-
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO MEET WITH ME TO DISCUSS SOME
OF THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL.
SPECIFICALLY CONCERNING THE
POST GRADUATE TRAINING LICENSE.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
STAFF ARE ALSO TAKING THE TIME
TO SPEAK WITH ME AND OTHERS
ABOUT THIS ISSUE. AS YOU KNOW
SENATOR RON. I ALONG WITH MANY
OTHERS HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS.
ABOUT THE UNINTENDED YET
PROBLEMATIC CONSEQUENCES. OF
OUR EXISTING POST GRADUATE
TRAINING LICENSE REQUIREMENTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE ESTABLISH THE POST
GRADUATE TRAINING LICENSE WHICH
CREATED BARRIERS FOR OUR
POSITION RESIDENTS TO PROVIDE
THE BEST CARE POSSIBLE FOR
THEIR PATIENTS. IT ALSO
SIGNIFICANTLY LIMITED OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS FROM
RECEIVING TIMELY PRIMARY CARE
DUE TO THE INABILITY OF OUR
RESIDENT PHYSICIANS TO
MOONLIGHT AND COMMUNITY CLINICS.
ALTHOUGH I HOPE THAT I WOULD
HAVE SEEN THE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE
IN THIS BILL TO RESOLVE THESE
OBSTACLES THAT WERE PUT IN
PLACE BY THE PTO. I KNOW THAT
AMENDMENTS CONTAINING INTENT
LANGUAGE TO RESOLVE THIS WENT
INTO PRINT TODAY. AS A MEMBER
OF APPROPRIATIONS I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING A RESOLUTION
ON THE PTO ISSUE IN THAT
COMMITTEE WHEN WE RETURN FOR
SUMMER RECESS. I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY TO
ENSURE THAT THE MEDICAL BOARD
CAN CONTINUE ITS GOOD WORK OF
PROTECTING CONSUMERS. AND
BECAUSE OF THE INTENT LANGUAGE
ON THE PTL ISSUE. I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE
RESOLUTION THAT SOLVE THESE
REAL IMPACTS THAT ARE EXISTING
LICENSURE FRAMEWORK. HAS ON OUR
CURRENT AND PROSPECTIVE WORK
FORCE AND SAFETY NET CLINICS.
THANK YOU CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DR WEBER. EXCEPT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG. I THINK IT WAS
CHAIR OF FIRST ALLIED OFFICER
THEY WANT TO APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS BY MY BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO- AND THE WORK-
BY YOUR DOCTOR- BY. BY YOUR
CHAIR ROTH WITHOUT THE WORK
YOU'RE PUTTING INTO WORKING OUT
A SOLUTION TO THE POST GRADUATE
LICENSING- REPORTED ALSO SEE
THE SPECIFICS. WHICH I THINK
ARE IMPORTANT TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO- HEALTHCARE IN MY
AREA I JUST REAL COMMUNITIES-
AND HOSPITALS. SO CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE- YOUR COMMITMENT TO
THAT I DID WANT TO- MOVE TO AND
FOCUS MORE ON THAT THE COP THEM
FORTUNATE MECHANISMS AND THE
CONCERNS- ROUND THAT I BELIEVE
IN OUR LAST- CENSORED HEARING
ON THIS- YOU. OUTLINED SOME
CONCERNS UNDER EXAMPLES THAT
YOU'VE HEARD- I THINK- A CHIRLA
ALSO YOU KNOW HAD EXAMPLES OF.
OF- A BAD ACTORS- THAT- I
THINK- WERE NOT- PROPERLY
REVIEWED AND- AND ADMONISHED BY
THE MEDICAL BOARD SO I WOULDN'T
WANT TO AT LEAST GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON. THE SPECIFICS OF
THE ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS IN
THIS BILL- HOW THE DISPARATE
ACTIONS ARE CAN BE MORE ROBUST.
AND IF YOU COULD ADDRESS- IS OF
THE COMPANY LETTERS OF- THAT I
THINK THE- MADE AWAY- YOU KNOW
HOW THAT GOING TO OPERATE. I
KNOW THAT I HAVE A NUMBER OF.
IN TO- THAT HAVE BEEN. TO HAVE
CONCERN ABOUT THAT'S WHY LIKE
TO SEE GET GET YOUR- ON THAT.
CERTAINLY OF. WHAT WE HEARD WAS
OF COURSE. INFORMATION THAT WAS
PASSED ON THAT WASN'T
NECESSARILY PASSED ON TO US BY
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON THIS BUT
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING CERTAINLY
I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT THE
PROBLEMS HAVE TO DO WITH
PHYSICIANS AND PHYSICIAN
DISCIPLINE AND THEIR DESIRE.
OBVIOUSLY WELL PLACED TO HAVE
CONFIDENTIALITY REGARDING THESE
CASES AND SO WHEN WE ASK ABOUT
THE CASE INCLUDING OF A TRAGIC
CASE THAT WAS THAT WAS DETAILED
OF OVER SOME PERIOD OF TIME
DURING OUR HEARING THE TOOK
OVER A MATTER OF TEN OR ELEVEN
YEARS TO GET TO THE ACCUSATION-
WHEN I ASK QUESTIONS WE SENT A
LETTER IS FOR RESPONSE WE'RE
TOLD- THE CASES IN LITIGATION
IT'S A CONFIDENTIAL. MATTER AND
WE CAN'T PROVIDE YOU ANY
INFORMATION. SO I'VE NOT BEEN
ON THIS BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS TRAIN. BEFORE THIS
YEAR THIS IS MY FIRST RODEO BUT
WHAT I HAVE DECIDED IS IT'S
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO COME UP
WITH A FIX PARTICULARLY WITH
THE MEDICALBOARD AND WITH
PHYSICIANS. WHEN WE CAN'T GET
TO THE DATA TO DECIDE WHETHER
THE PROCESS IS GOOD BAD OR
INDIFFERENT WHETHER THE CASES
ARE BEING SETTLED PROPERLY OR
IMPROPERLY BECAUSE WE CAN'T GET
THE DATA REGARDING THE
PHYSICIAN MISCONDUCT. INVOLVED
REDACTED OR OTHERWISE. AND SO
WITH RESPECT TO THE PUBLIC
MEMBER PROCESS SOME OF YOU MAY
KNOW. WE I PUT THE PUBLIC
MEMBER PROVISION IN THE SENATE
BILL INITIALLY BECAUSE I
THOUGHT THAT WAS THE WAY TO GO.
BUT WHAT I CONCLUDED WAS WE
HAVE PUBLIC MEMBERS ON THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
NOT JUST THE MAJORITY. THEY'RE
NOT A MAJORITY BUT WE HAVE
PUBLIC MEMBERS AND PART OF THE
PROCESS IS THE PUBLIC MEMBERS
ON THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT INVOLVED IN
THE ENFORCEMENT PROCESS FROM
THE BEGINNING. THEY'RE INVOLVED
AT SOME LATER STAGE OF THE
PROCESS AND THE QUESTION IS THE
ENTIRE PROCESS DOES THE ENTIRE
PROCESS WORK IS IT EFFECTIVE.
WE ALSO LEARNED AS YOU MAY
RECALL THAT THEY SETTLE. I
DON'T KNOW 82% OF THEIR CASES
IN. EIGHTY SOMETHING PERCENT OF
THE OF THOSE CASES THE
SETTLEMENTS FAILED TO MEET. THE
DISCIPLINARY GUIDELINES THAT
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC ITSELF PROMULGATED AND
PUBLISHED. SO WE NEED TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THAT WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT IS WHY THEY
HAVE A HIGH SETTLEMENT RATE WHY
MORE ARE TRIED. AND WHEN THEY
DO HAVE A SETTLEMENT RATE WHY
DON'T THE SETTLEMENTS MEET THE
DISCIPLINARY GUIDELINES. ADDING
ONE OR TWO. OR THREE PUBLIC
MEMBERS TO THE BOARD SINCE
THEY'RE NOT INVOLVED IN THE
INTER DISCIPLINARY PROCESS I
DON'T THINK GETS IS THERE AND
SO. WE DECIDED YES THERE'S BEEN
AN ENFORCEMENT MONITOR IN THE
BOARD LONG BEFORE MY TIME BUT
WE DECIDED TO PUT AN
ENFORCEMENT MATTER INTO THE
BOARD. WITH THE PROCESS THAT
HOPEFULLY HAS SOME TEETH ON IT
IN IT AND IF IT DOESN'T WE'LL
PUT SOME TEETH TO IT. REQUIRE
PERIODIC REPORTS AND A FINAL
REPORT SO WE CAN GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF HOW THIS ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS THE MEDICAL BOARD
WORKS. AND WHETHER THE MEDICAL
BOARD IS IN FACT TAKING
APPROPRIATE. DISCIPLINARY
ACTION AGAINST PHYSICIANS WHO
VIOLATE THE STANDARD OF CARE
ONE BECAUSE SOME OF ITS MEDICAL
MALPRACTICE ALLEGATIONS. THE
STUFF YOU HEARD ABOUT TODAY
OVER THE- ON THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY. AND SOME OF IT HAS
TO DO WITH PHYSICIAN MISCONDUCT
ALCOHOL ABUSE SUBSTANCE ABUSE-
LACK OF HONESTY IN TERMS OF
IMPORTANT ISSUES THE LEAST
IMPORTANT MEDICAL BOARD A WHOLE
VARIETY OF OTHER THINGS AND WE
NEED TO ANALYZE THAT SO
HOPEFULLY. THIS ENFORCEMENT
MONITOR PROCESS WILL GET TO THE
HEART OF THAT WILL PROVIDE US
THE DATA THAT WE NEED IN THIS
COMMITTEE. IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE COMMITTEE IN
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS TO MAKE
SOME DETERMINATION AND SOME
ADJUSTMENT WITH RESPECT TO THE
WAY THIS. MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA WORKS AND THEN AT
THAT POINT IN TIME. WE CAN ONCE
AGAIN ADDRESSED THE ISSUE A
PUBLIC MEMBERSHIP BECAUSE
REMEMBER THIS IS NOT THE ONLY.
HEALING ARTS BOARD IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND IF THIS
BOARD NEEDS PUBLIC MEMBERS SO
TO THE OTHER BY A PUBLIC MEMBER
MAJORITY SO TO THE OTHER
BOARDS. IN CALIFORNIA WE MUST
WILL TACKLE THOSE TWO. THAT I'M
CLOSE TO ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTION SIR YES IT DID- I DID
WANT TO- DID YOU ENVISION THE
INDEPENDENT FOR SOME WATER TO
HAVE- MORE RESPONSIBILITY HOW
DOES IT COMPARE TO- PREVIOUS-
AND FOR SOME WATER SO I WASN'T
HERE SO LIKE I WASN'T HERE
EITHER SO I CAN'T ADDRESS THAT
BUT WHAT WE WHAT I MEAN BUT WE
INTEND IS THAT THE ENFORCEMENT
MINOR HAVE FULL ACCESS TO THE
PROCESS. LIKE DATA ANALYZED
APPROPRIATENESS.
INAPPROPRIATENESS PRESSES THESE
THAT NEED TO BE CHANGED. AND
PROVIDE US A REPORT AND WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT IS HOW WE GET THE SPECIFIC
DATA WITHOUT GETTING THE-
WITHOUT BREACHING THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF THESE
PERSONAL MATTERS THE COMPANY.
THAT YOU KNOW THE DISCIPLINE
CASES INVOLVE POSITIONS BUT
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO CRACK THAT
NUT BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND. WHY THE SETTLEMENT
RATES HIGH Y. THE WHY THE
DISCIPLINARY GUIDELINES ARE MET.
N. Y. MORE CASES ARE TRIED
MAYBE THERE. WAS A MAYBE
THERE'S A REASON MAYBE THEY'RE
TAKING TOO MANY COMPLAINTS
COMPLAINTS THAT DON'T REALLY
HAVE- GRAVITAS IT. AT ALL
LEVELS AND THEN THEY SETTLE
THEM THEY CAN'T THEY CAN I
DON'T KNOW I DON'T THINK ANY OF
US. AND TO GET TO THE LETTER OF
ADVICE THAT WE REQUEST BY. THE
BOARD PERHAPS TO HIM THOSE. LOW
LOW LEVEL. VIOLATE YOU KNOW
THAT DON'T NECESSARILY NEED THE
MORE FORMAL PROCESS WHERE YOU
HAVE AN INVESTIGATION
ACCUSATION INVOLVEMENT BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND ALL
THE REST WHICH DRIVE FRANKLY
DRIVES UP THE COST AND IN
APPROPRIATE CASES THAT PROCESS
SHOULD BE FOLLOWED AND IN
APPROPRIATE CASES CASES SHOULD
BE TRIED BUT WE NEED TO SORT OF
TRIAGE THIS AND THAT THAT WAS
THE RATIONALE FOR THE BOARD'S
REQUEST FOR THE LETTER OF
ADVICE. FIVE I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER I KNOW I
AGREE WITH YOU I THINK YOU'VE
I'VE I THINK YOU'VE HIGHLIGHTED
ALL THE KEY CHALLENGES THAT WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON THE DATA IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT SO I KNOW
YOUR COMMITMENT TO PATIENT
SAFETY SO- I WOULD LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN TERMS OF
MAKING OF LOOKING AT THE DATA
AND SEEING THAT WE HAVE TO MAKE
THE AND THE ENFORCEMENT
PROVISIONS MORE OF US THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WELL I WOULD JUST
THAT I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT. THE
LETTER OF VICE THE LETTER OF
ADVICE PROCESS WAS NOT INCLUDED
TO CLOSE CLOSE THIS
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS IN IN ANY
MORE SECRECY THAN THAN IT.
SEEMS TO HAVE SO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER JR. CENTER I
HAD A COUPLE QUESTIONS RELATING
TO THE COST RECOVERY FEES. MY
FIRST QUESTION IS IT. UNDER
THIS BILL WITH THE COST
RECOVERY. PAUL ALTERNATELY ON
THE PHYSICIAN OR ON THE
POSITIONS- MALPRACTICE
INSURANCE CARRIER I DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER TO THAT I WOULD
SUSPECT THAT IT HAS TO DO WITH
THE MALPRACTICE POLICY
PROVISIONS BUT I DON'T REALLY
KNOW. AND THE COST RECOVERY
OBVIOUSLY APPLIES WHEN THERE'S-
WHEN SOMEBODY'S LOST. YES
RECOVER COSTS SO THE IF YOU YOU
KNOW IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
APPLY IF YOU SETTLE A CASE
UNLESS THERE'S SOME AGREEMENT
SO IF 82% OF YOUR COMPLAINTS
ARE SETTLED. IF THAT REMAINS A
STATISTIC I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A HUGE
NUMBER OF CASES BUT ONCE AGAIN
I'M GUESSING TO SOME EXTENT WE
ASK FOR SOME PROJECTIONS ON
REVENUE RECOVERY ASSOCIATED
WITH. WITH THE COST RECOVERY
PRESENT A PROVISION IN. THE
DATA THAT WE WERE PROVIDED AT
LEAST IN AN INFORMAL WAY
SUGGESTS THAT IT'S IN THE LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS POTENTIALLY.
OKAY SO I'M CURIOUS AS TO YOUR
RESPONSE TO THAT I GUESS CMA'S
CONCERN THEY REYES WHICH-
STRIKES ME AS IT MIGHT BE A
WELL FOUNDED CONCERN WHICH IS
THE SENSE THAT. THE COSTSOF
THE INVESTIGATIONS ARE HARD TO
KNOW UP FRONT AND CAN BE HIGHLY
VARIABLE AND SOME OF THEM. I'M
ASSUMING FROM WHAT THEY SAY CAN
BE VERY. EXPENSIVE BY INSERTING
A COST RECOVERY BACK IN THE
SCHEME- OR THE SYSTEM I SHOULD
SAY- ARE YOU CREATING AN
INCENTIVE FOR PEOPLE TO.
LEVERAGE THE POTENTIAL OF AN
EXPENSIVE COST RECOVERY THAT'S
GOING TO BE THE BILL FOR WHICH
WILL BE LAID. AT THE POSITION
STORE OR THEIR CARRIER ONE OF
THE TWO- JAHRBUCH ARE. ARE IS
THAT COULD BE ABUSED IN A
WHERE'S OUR POTENTIAL FOR ABUSE
TO LEVERAGE. PEOPLE INTO JUST
RESOLVING TO GET IT DONE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO END
UP WITH. A HIGH SIX FIGURE BILL
FOR THE INVESTIGATIVE COSTS
WELL THEY DON'T HAVE IT NOW
REMEMBER AND THESE THE THEY'RE
SETTLING I DON'T REMEMBER
82284% OF MAY HAVE BEEN EIGHTY
FOUR PERCENT. 84% OF THE CASES
NOW SO I DON'T KNOW. THAT THAT
CMA CONCERN HAS ANY LEGS
FRANKLY. OKAY THAT'S THAT'S
FAIR I LOOK AT THE SETTLEMENT
PIECE ACTUALLY FROM THE MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY I DON'T
KNOW THAT THAT'S EVIDENCE THAT
THE SYSTEM ISN'T WORKING. I
MEAN GENERALLY ACROSS ALL SORTS
OF. TYPES OF- DISPUTES I MEAN-
A HIGH SETTLEMENT RATE IS.
OFTEN A GOOD SIGN. RIGHT I MEAN
YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE RESOLVING
THEIR THEIR THINGS WITHOUT.
EXPENSIVE LONGER JUDICATA
PROCESS OF IT WELL I THINK IF I
CAN RESPOND I MEAN. THE SUNSET
REVIEW HEARINGS AND YOU HAD
CASES WHERE. THE POSITION
RECEIVED A LETTER OF REPRIMAND
AND IT WAS A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CASES I'M REMEMBERING. YOU HAVE
PHYSICIANS WHO PERHAPS GOT A
LETTER RECEIVED A LETTER OF
REPRIMAND OR WHATEVER THE-
WHATEVER THE TERM IS- IN CASES
WHERE. THERE WAS AN ADMITTED TO
INSTANCE OF- OF DISHONESTY. SO
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I DO KNOW IS
THE MEDICAL BOARD ITSELF HAS
TOLD US. THAT IN A HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF THOSE SETTLEMENT
CASES THE DISCIPLINARY
GUIDELINES WHATEVER THEY CALL
THEM. VETERAN REGULATION THAT
THEY PROMULGATED. WE'RE NOT.
ONE OR MORE THE CENTRAL ISSUE
CENTREPOINT NOT SATISFIED SO
THEY'RE NOT MEETING THEIR OWN
DISCIPLINARY GUIDELINES IN THE
DISCIPLINE THAT THEY'RE
IMPOSING. IN SETTLEMENT SO.
THAT MAY BE A PROBLEM IT'S
CERTAINLY INDICATED BY SOME OF
THE TELEPHONE CALLS THAT IN
TESTIMONY THAT WE RECEIVED HERE
IN THAT WE RECEIVED DURING THE
SUNSET REVIEW BUT WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THAT I DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION. TO DRAW A
CONCLUSION MYSELF AND I SUSPECT
YOU WILL FEEL THE SAME. I
APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWERS THANK
YOU. I WILL NOT ON THE COST
RECOVERY THAT THE IRONY OF. THE
CMA'S POSITION IS NOT LOST ON
ME. OPPOSED TO COST RECOVERY
WHICH HAS SOME REVENUE
GENERATING POTENTIAL IN TERMS
OF THOSE CASES THAT DRAG ON.
PERHAPS BECAUSE OF PHYSICIANS
DRAGOMAN. AND AT THE SAME TIME
ARGUING AGAINST A FEE INCREASE
FOR MEDICAL BOARD THAT IS IN
SELF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
EDUCATIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME. SEIGNER
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME. EMIRATI WISH TO CLOSE. D.
WELL LET ME JUST IF I COULD
MAKE ONE OTHER POINT TO THOSE
OF LICENSED MIDWIVES I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN AND THE
INTEREST IN ESTABLISHING A ON A
NEW LICENSED. MIDWIFERY BOARD
OF FRANKLY THOUGH WE NEED TO DO
MORE FINANCIAL ANALYSIS- TO
ENSURE THAT THE LICENSE FEES
THAT THE LICENSED MIDWIVES. ARE
GOING TO PAY ARE WILLING TO PAY
OR SUFFICIENT TO FUND THE BOARD
BECAUSE OF YOU ALL KNOW THESE
BOARDS ARE SPECIAL FUNDED. AND
NOT GENERAL FUND AND THE
LICENSEES HAVE TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATION THAT WE
SET UP SO I PLEDGE TO THOSE WHO
CALLED AND I PLEDGE TO DO THAT
I'M NOT SURE LOW JOINS ME IN
THAT IT WILL TAKE ANOTHER LOOK
AT THIS AND SEE WHAT WE NEED TO
DO. SO WITH THAT HELLO- THIS
BILL IMPORTANTLY CONTINUES NOT
ONLY THE OPERATIONS OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD WITH THE
OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL BOARD THE
PODIA TRICK MEDICAL BOARD AND
THE PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT BOARD.
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO
RESPECTFULLY US FOR NOT VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHARON
ROTH- AGAIN I'D LIKE TO COMMEND
YOU. FOR TAKING ON THIS.
POSITION AS THE CHAIR OF THE
SENATE BUSINESS PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE IN WHICH- YOU DO NOT
ASK FOR THIS. AND THAT YOU'RE
THROWN IN TO HELP DIVE INTO
VERY. DIFFICULT COMPLEX ISSUES
WITH. SIXTEEN OR SO BOARDS AND
BUREAUS- THIS YEAR AND I KNOW
THAT WE YOU AND I ARE.
COMMITTED TO IRON OUT MANY OF
THESE ISSUES. IN THE INTERIM
AND MOVING FORWARD. ALSO LIKE
TO THANK THE ADVOCATES AND
PATIENTS WHO HAVE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH OUR RESPECTIVE
OFFICES. PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO
HAVE. EXPERIENCED GREAT LOSS.
DUE TO MAKE A MEDICAL
NEGLIGENCE. MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WILL ALSO RECALL THAT
WE HAVE HAD MULTIPLE OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS. IN WHICH WE'VE
EXPRESSED CONSIDERABLE
FRUSTRATIONS WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD'S FAILURE TO BE.
PROACTIVE AND PROTECT PATIENTS.
AND IN FACT JUST THIS MORNING
IN THE LA TIMES ARTICLE. FOUND
THAT NEARLY OUT OF THE NINETY
THOUSAND COMPLAINTS AGAINST
DOCTORS. OVER THE PAST DECADE
LESS THAN HALF A PERCENT
RESULTED IN A LICENSE.
REVOCATION THIS OF COURSE IS
EITHER A STATISTICAL ANOMALY.
OR COMPLETE FAILURE BY THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO TAKE ACTION TO
PROTECT EVERYDAY CALIFORNIANS.
AND NOW WE ARE NOT ADDRESSING A
NUMBER OF OUTSTANDING ISSUES I
KNOW. GERMAN ROTH AND I STAND
DEEPLY COMMITTED. TO ADDRESSING
THOSE ISSUES MOVING FORWARD.
BUT LET'S MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT WHILE WE ARE EXTENDING THE
BOARD. SENSE AT EXTENSION FOR
TWO YEARS. THE BOARD IS
CERTAINLY NOT OFF THE HOOK. I
KNOW THAT SHERMAN ROSS SHARES
THE DEEP COMMITMENT TO ENSURING
STRONG OVERSIGHT. OVER THE
COMING YEARS AND WILL CONTINUE
TO MAN ANSWERS. BUT THE
RESPECTIVE. CHAIRS AND
COMMITTEE STAFF ALONG WITH
MEMBERS OF THESE COMMITTEES. I
ALSO WANT TO ENSURE AND
ENCOURAGE AND REAFFIRMED HIS.
COMMENTS BY DR WEBER AND
ADDRESSING OUTSTANDING ISSUES
AND I KNOW THAT WILL
COLLECTIVELY. WORK OUT THOSE
ISSUES AS IT CONTINUES TO MOVE
FORWARD. AS WELL AS A HAVING
REPORTS FROM INDEPENDENT. AND
FOR SMALL MONITOR WHO HELPED
STRENGTH IN THE PROCESS WITH
INFORMED RECOMMENDATIONS. TO
HAVING SAY THAT- THIS DOES
ENJOYED PASS A- AND WE NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND. WITH BY A
SUMMER BLOOM TAKEN BY DR WEBBER
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SB EIGHT ZERO SIX
ROTH DO YOU PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORA. FLOOR NOT VOTING
BERMAN BERMAN HI BLOOM LOOM HI
CHEN. CHIU CHIU HI CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING TALLY.
DALY NOT VOTING FONG. ON NOT
VOTING GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN. IRWIN HI
MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA HI
MULLIN MULLIN I SALAS. TEAM
WEBER WEBER HI. ELEVEN I ZERO
KNOWS ELEVEN EYES ZERO KNOWS-
IS GERMONT WILL LEAVE IT WILL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
OUR CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP AND
DEDICATION AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JUST
BEFORE WE HEAD INTO THE FINAL
VOTE I JUST WANT TO REMIND
MEMBERS ON SUNSET BILLS A NO
VOTE. MEANS THAT WE WILL
ELIMINATE THE BOARDS AND
BUREAUS SO NO VOTE SIGNIFIES
THAT THE BOARD WILL EXPIRE
JANUARY ONE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWO JUST TO REAFFIRM. THAT
PIECE OF INFORMATION SO WE'LL
GO BACK IN TO FOLLOW ORDER THEN.
TO TACKLE THE ADD ONS. ALAVA
COMMITTEE SECTOR TO GO AND
FOLLOW ORDER. CONSENT ITEMS SB
EIGHT HUNDRED ARCHULETA S. B.
EIGHT TWO SIX BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHIU CHIU HI
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM HI
HOLDEN HOLDEN HI MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN. MULLIN HI
TAKING. EIGHTEEN I ZERO KNOWS.
SB SIX ZERO SEVEN MILLION DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS QIU
QIU HI CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
HI HOLDEN HOLDEN HI MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HI MULLIN MULLIN HI
TEAM. EIGHTEEN HI ZERONOS. SB
EIGHT ZERO ONE ARCHER LETTER TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU. CHIU AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI DALLI
DALLI HI HOLDEN HOLDEN HI
MCCARTY MCCARTY HI MULLIN
MULLIN HI TEAM. EIGHTEEN ICE
ZERONOS. SB EIGHT ZERO TWO ROTH
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
HOLDEN. HOLDEN HI MCCARTY
MCCARTY HI MULLIN MULLIN I.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN IS THE
ZERONOS. SB EIGHT ZERO THREE
ROTH TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FLORA. FLOREN
NOW CHIU CHIU HI MCCARTY
MCCARTY HI TEAM. SIXTEEN I IS
ONE NOW. S. B. EIGHT ZERO SIX
ROTH TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MCCARTY MCCARTY I SALAS. K.
TWELVE FIVE ZERO NOTE.
THE JOB
DESCRIPTION. THEY WERE. THE.
YOU CAN SEND ITEMS SB EIGHT
HUNDRED ARCHULETA SB EIGHT TO
SIX BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS THANK.
TíNH I. NINETEEN I ZERO KNOWS.
SB SIX ZERO SEVEN MEN TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS TANG. TEN HI.
NINETEEN FIVE ZERO NO. SB EIGHT
ZERO ONE OR TWO LETTER TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
TANG. KING I. NINETY NINE ZERO
KNOWS. SB EIGHT ZERO TWO ROTH
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS TEN.
TEN NINE NINETEEN AYE AYES ZERO
NOW. SB EIGHT ZERO THREE ROTH
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS TANG. THE TEAM I.
SEVENTEEN I WON NO. SB EIGHT
ZERO SIX ROB TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS TANG. TEN NOT
VOTING. THE FACT THAT.
WELL.
OKAY MY BOYS. YEAH SO. REPLY
FALL.
YEAH.
OKAY- AB OKAY. YEAH
I'M. I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS
THERE ARE YOU.
WE GOT. WE ARE
CURRENT THANK YOU.